welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford School of Medicine my guest
today is Chris Voss
Chris Foss spent more than two decades
as an agent with the FBI or Federal
Bureau of Investigation where he was a
lead crisis negotiator and a member of
The Joint terrorist task force Chris is
also the author of a phenomenal
best-selling book entitled never split
the difference in addition he has taught
courses in negotiation at Harvard at
Georgetown and at the University of
Southern California as a world expert in
all forms of negotiation today Chris
teaches us about how to hold hard
conversations where we are seeking
particular outcomes or perhaps where we
don't know what the optimal outcome
could be he talks about this in the
context of business in the context of
relationships including romantic
relationships but familial and work
relationships as well and he talks about
how we should think about ourselves in
the context of negotiations so that we
can all arrive at the best possible
outcomes indeed during today's episode
you will learn to pay attention to
emotions not just other people's
emotions but your own emotions in order
to to determine whether or not you are
processing the information you're
hearing accurately and equally important
whether or not you are being heard
accurately when you are in a discussion
of any kind but especially heated
discussions in addition we discuss the
role of both physical and mental stamina
in the context of difficult
conversations negotiations and decision
making because in the real world context
oftentimes those can take place not just
within a single conversation but over
the course of several days or even
several weeks months or years Chris also
teaches us about deception that is how
to determine if somebody is lying by
asking particular types of probe
questions thanks to Chris voss's both
bread and depth of expertise in the
negotiation process that he gleaned
during his more than two decade service
in the FBI as well as his generosity in
sharing that information by the end of
today's episode you will have an
excellent understanding of what the
negotiation process is really all about
and how to better carry out those
negotiations so that they can best serve
you and others before we begin I'd like
to emphasize that this podcast is
separate from my teaching and research
roles at Stanford it is however part of
my desire and effort to bring zero cost
and consumer information about science
and science related tools to the general
public in keeping with that theme I'd
like to thank the sponsors of today's
podcast our first sponsor is Plunge
plunge makes what I believe is the most
versatile at-home self-cooling cold
plunge for deliberate cold exposure
talk numerous times on this podcast
about the many benefits of deliberate
cold exposure deliberate cold exposure
especially deliberate cold exposure done
up to the neck in water can be used to
achieve a number of important endpoints
related to mental health physical health
and performance plunge uses a powerful
cooling filtration and sanitation unit
to give you access to deliberate cold
exposure in clean water whenever you
want I've been using a plunge for more
than two years now I can tell you that
it makes it very easy to get your
deliberate cold exposure at home it
doesn't require much cleaning in fact
it's very easy to keep clean which is
essential you don't want bacteria and
other things growing in your cold plunge
basically everything about the plunge is
made easy so that anyone including
myself can gather deliberate cold
exposure on a regular basis at home if
you're interested in getting a plunge
you can go to plunge Spell
p-l-u-n-g-e.com slash huberman and get
150 off your cold plunge again that's
plunge.com huberman for 150 off today's
episode is also brought To Us by Roca r
Roku makes eyeglasses and sunglasses
that are the absolute highest quality
I've spent a lifetime working on the
biology the visual system and I can tell
you that your visual system has to
contend with an enormous number of
challenges in order for you to be able
to see clearly in different environments
Roka understands the biology of the
visual system and has designed their
eyeglasses and sunglasses so that you
always see with Crystal Clarity
originally their glasses were designed
for performance that is for running and
cycling and for sport and indeed they
can still be used for performance they
won't slip off your face if you get
sweaty they're extremely lightweight but
I should mention that Roca eyeglasses
and sunglasses come in some of the
Aesthetics more typically associated
with performance glasses like those
cyborg style glasses but they also have
a number of styles that you would be
perfectly comfortable wearing out to
dinner or to work I wear readers at
night or when I drive and I wear
sunglasses during the day if I happen to
be driving into bright light or outside
and it's just overwhelmingly bright I do
not wear sunglasses when I do my morning
sunlight viewing to set my circadian
rhythm and I suggest that you do the
same if you'd like to try Roca
eyeglasses or sunglasses you can go to
Roka roka.com and enter the code
huberman to save 20 off your first order
again that's Roca roka.com and enter the
code huberman at checkout and now for my
conversation with Chris Voss
Chris Voss welcome
Andrew pleasure man I've been wanting to
talk to you on record for a while you
are
quite the what we call in signs n of one
when somebody is a true sample size of
one
uh I realized that yes you are because
you have this incredible skill set from
your time in the FBI you but you also
have an incredible understanding and
knowledge of how to communicate about
that skill set so that people can glean
useful information from it
you are also the guy that I text or call
every once in a while and I've run
myself into a jam or when I think I
might be in a jam and I won't reveal
details but you tell me whether or not
things are okay unfortunately the last
couple times I reached out you said
you're good so thank you always happy to
help man thank you well I have a lot of
questions today but
what I'd like to start off talking about
is
negotiations take many forms
but if we could break those down into
their broad categories that will be
useful
but before we do that
I want to know about the mindset that
you have when you go into a negotiation
and whether or not there are any sort of
practices I realize you've been in this
profession a long time and so it perhaps
became reflexive to you at some point
but all of us at some point are going to
go into negotiations business
negotiations relationship negotiations
Etc is there a process of getting one's
mind and body right for a negotiation
shifting from more listening and less
talking or what are there any tools that
you use on the regular that could be
useful for us to keep in mind as we
extend into the different categories of
negotiations and ways to approach those
negotiations and it can there can be a
couple different
um
first of all just trying to figure out
what what's really going on is is the
real issue and then how can I get an
approach where I'm most likely to get
the best possible outcome
um so there's always more than meets the
eye
and there's a certain there's a certain
few cliches but the real issue is
there's always a better deal or
um there's no deal at all
so first of all trying to my first thing
is I want to find out whether or not
there's a deal at all or whether or not
it's a bad deal
and then I'm going to walk away really
fast because those are going to be
complete waste of time
um it's not a sin to not get the deal
let's just send to take a long time to
not get the deal
what's the sin to take a long time to
get a bad deal
so I you know I want to know I'm going
to try to figure out real quick whether
or not is there Cutthroat on the other
side of the table is it somebody I could
trust
I'm getting I'm leaning a little more
inclined to dealing with the difficult
people now as long as I don't give in
so I gotta I want to diagnose early on
what the possibilities are
now if I'm curious if I'm actually
interested
now another aspect of the mindset is
if I'm in a great mood
like if I'm just gonna be playful
a couple of really
huge personal negotiation wins recently
was when I was just trying to be playful
I mean I was just I was in a great mood
and I'm joking around and great
negotiation is not exciting it's
astonishing
um I'm gonna come we're in conversations
right now with a possible non-scripted
TV show
and so I was telling the producers
you know this ain't going to be real
housewives
um for to make this show properly there
ain't gonna be any screaming
it's not going to be Bar Rescue where
we're yelling at people we're not going
to be Hell's Kitchen where we're yelling
at people
it's never going to be exciting but it
is going to be astonishing
you'll get outcomes where suddenly you
find yourself in a place like what in
the world
how did that just happen
and so I I lose a suitcase in an airport
the other day
and I'm walking into the lost luggage
place and I'm in a great mood because
I'm home and I'm happy to be home
and I'm going to get a good night's
sleep and even though it's late in the
day I'm just happy
and are you ready to walk into this the
lost luggage store where these people
are better children
like they expect you
they know that you expect them to wave a
magic wand and proof your luggage is
going to be there
so for whatever reason that's what I say
when I walk in the doors young lady says
how can I help you well first of all how
you could help me is obvious because I'm
in a lost luggage there's only one
reason I'm in here so that's kind of a
silly question
and I go I need you to wave a magic wand
and she just laughs and she looks at me
she ends up walking me out to the
Carousel climbing up on the Carousel and
she walks down a ramp the luggage comes
out of and I guarantee you they're not
supposed to do that and she sticks her
head and she looks around she comes back
out and I've never seen any of these
people leave the office let alone walk
back to the carousel and she says wait
here and she she disappears into the
bowels of the airport which like looks
like a super highway down there right
like God knows what it looks like
underneath the airport
and pretty soon the carousel starts up
again
and my bag and another bag pops out this
other Porsche Mark is sitting there
waiting and I'm like I have never seen
anybody do this ever
like normally they say here's a number
we'll call you in 24 hours it might show
up at your house
and I look around at the uh there's
another young lady there and I say
you know please tell her thank you for
me I gotta go because she she doesn't
come back out for like almost 10 minutes
and on my way out she she comes out the
door and she high fives me and she says
how does that for waving a magic wand
and that was the magic phrase and I
never would have said it to her if I
wasn't playful in a moment
and I've got a couple of others like
when I was just playful and I'm joking
with people
almost at my expense it's shocking
astonishing
where you can get people to do if you if
you hit them the right way
so interesting I wonder what it tapped
into but it sounds like it might have
tapped into her sense that everybody's
always asking me for a magic wand kind
of ability but finally somebody just
said it directly and that would be kind
of fun to to actually play that role
because normally they're restricted to
their keyboard and their phone yeah you
know I love that
on the opposite side of that Spectrum if
ever you're feeling tense stressed jet
lagged angry
um you know I can think about
negotiations where like people are
trying to keep their egos in check they
want to be right
um you know the breakups negotiations
there's not necessarily romantic
breakups that could include that but
also professional breakups you know the
the dissolution of a of a contract or
something like that
do you ever have to check yourself like
okay I need to I mean I imagine being
calm is better than not being calm for
most of most all things
um uh do you have a process of doing
that you seem like a pretty steady guy
I've never seen you uh
[Laughter]
overall I'm pretty steady
um well
the late night FM DJ voice that
um I'm not sure that I coined the phrase
but kind of famous for
to calm you down also calms me down
so if I get bent out of shape
um I will in a conversation gets heated
I'll switch into that voice with the
intention of calming you down because
you know that's the that's the hostage
negotiator's voice
but it'll calm me down too like
intentionally going to that voice
tamps down the negative emotions which
I'm convinced make me Dumber in the
moment interfere with my capacity to
process information got reasons for that
Layman's reasons no scientific
academically rigorous studies that have
been in any journals well after you're
done I'm going to tell you something
that will perhaps be astonishing to you
as to why there's real Neuroscience
behind that late night FM DJ voice
having an impact on other people's
brains
but yeah and I'll do that because it
calms me down
now if I can if I can make this shift
the hard part is to shift into a
positive mindset
if I can make that shift
but I can only make it from a calm voice
I also think it's the emotions are kind
of a rock paper scissors sequence
I don't think you can go from sadness to
Elation directly
sad um depressed down
I think there's something to
um getting angry to pull you out of
sadness
and I think if you're angry you've got
to go to calm next
and so but if I can get out of anger and
go to calm then I can say something to
myself like
the reality is this is a luxury problem
or I was in a negotiation with a
counterpart that I knew was deceiving
lying to me
and I remember saying to myself you know
I'm lucky to be in this negotiation I
mean they wouldn't they wouldn't be
trying to hustle me
if we weren't really good if we didn't
have a product that was phenomenal I
wouldn't be targeted at all
so I'm actually lucky to be in this
conversation so if I can make that next
shift emotionally then I'm good the hard
part is making those chefs
I'm going to share with you what I
learned recently about sound and emotion
um I'm researching an episode on music
in the brain
fascinating topic believe it or not
there's a lot known and
the auditory system has this property
where of course there are neurons nerve
cells that respond to different
frequencies of sound low low frequency
you know deeper tones and high frequency
squeals and that sort of thing right
okay
that's pretty straightforward just like
we have neurons that respond to
different different colors or different
uh you know angles of light in in the
room right but what I learned and I
confirmed with a good friend of mine
who's an auditory neuroscientist and and
neurosurgeons named zetty Chang who was
a guest on this podcast previously is
that low frequency sounds
of the sort that your voice is
that late night fmdj voice
are responded to in the brain by neurons
no surprise there but the frequency that
those neurons fire
is also low frequency in other words
when you speak in your
low voice right
the other person's brain hears that and
starts firing in a low frequency tone
right in other words it entrains to your
voice not just the timing but it's
actually like you're essentially playing
an emotional piano down in the low keys
of their all right of their mind now
when you go up to the high frequencies
the neurons can't follow that high
frequency so there's something special
about low frequency sound that actually
changes the emotional tone of the people
that hear that low frequency sound
this is wild right I mean I mean of
course the content of the words matters
too
but anyway there's there's real
Neuroscience to support
um the voice that you were endowed with
and that you uh that you employed for
your work well then and then also the
point then too is it's not the other
side's not making a choice it's an
involuntary reaction that's right this
is not something one can override except
by perhaps plugging their ears right
right if they're hearing that their
their mind is getting shifted toward a
state of low frequency oscillation which
is one of more calm yeah so that yeah so
that's a real thing and and were you to
have a high squeaky Chipmunks voice
you might not have been The Negotiator
you had all that who knows maybe there'd
be another tactic there I mean I I think
back to the um uh what I guess it was
during one of the Gulf War campaigns
where they weren't they trying to um
squeeze out uh Saddam and some of uh his
people by playing like Milli Vanilli at
high volume for hours and hours is that
tactic actually used
um so that was that was uh Panama when
they were trying to get Noriega okay I'm
only a few I'm only a few countries
though see you know I had one ocean or I
got the trivia you know I was telling
you before and the wacky yeah
fascinating useless information around
terrorism and stuff like that I tried
that at Panama
and and for whatever the military guys
they were playing music at and sounds
and then
also among the many stupid things that
the FBI did at Waco
then late at night they tried that in
the Waco compound too and it was just
that was one of the things that the
hostage negotiators were adamantly
against adamantly against
but they got overruled
um by answering command among the many
stupid things that were done at Waco
that was also done at Waco it was stupid
it's counterproductive hostage
negotiators were always against it so
for those who don't remember Waco Waco
is um Branch Davidians uh David koresh
right yeah there was a Netflix series
that was out about it recently that's
fair
um about the how it went down yeah sad
ending he eventually set the the
building Ablaze killed himself and
everybody else and people inside set the
building on fire yeah including a lot of
children Parish including some children
some there are some uh FBI agents that
have still not gotten over that
luck to talk about some different types
of negotiations
um
oftentimes I think because you're a
former FBI negotiator
a terrorist task force this kind of
thing
um we tend to focus on the negative
negotiations right get the hostages away
and we'll talk about that stuff um
breakups business deals that have gone
wrong
um people lying cheating what about
negotiations that are benevolent let's
say that two people want to
um come to a true win-win around you
know what they each see to be their best
interests in let's say friendship two
friends taking a trip together vacation
who's gonna pay for what who's gonna pay
up front are people going to pay each
other back
um or a romantic relationship two people
are considering you know fusing finances
to some extent or moving in together
what sorts of questions should people be
asking themselves prior to those
negotiations in particular is it very
important that people know exactly what
they want going into a negotiation or I
can recall many times when I've gone
into life circumstances knowing I wanted
a certain set of feelings or outcomes
but not being extremely specific about
you know I want this salary I want to
live in you know in a west facing house
on this particular location you know an
exploration
um of potentials I think can also take
the form of negotiation so
how do how should people think about
approaching benevolent negotiations like
where we're not talking about something
tragic happening if it doesn't go
through it might hurt it might be a
little bit High friction but
let's talk about how to get to a win-win
yeah well there's a couple interesting
things there first of all you know the
phrase win-win because
win-win is just great collaboration I
mean an important fact it should be
win-win which might only be emotional
win-win now the phraseology win-win I
know that if someone's opens a
negotiation with me and they say right
off the bat look I want to do a win-win
deal with you
that correlates extremely highly
with someone who's trying to pick my
pocket
so I if you use that phrase in the first
five minutes
I already know where you're coming from
you're trying to get me to draw my
guards you when I lose
so and this came up on our Instagram
post I put up recently
which is essentially watch out for the
person says win-win
now I didn't say win-win is bad I said
watch out for the person that says it
also
you got to be cautious if if you're like
some of the win-win mindset
then people set themselves up to just
get slaughtered
by the person who's expressing a desire
for win-win and looking to pick their
pocket like if I feel win-win in my
heart you go let's do a win-win deal
if I don't watch it I'm like okay what
do you want and then I find myself
giving away the store so there's a lot
behind the win-win phraseology
that you have to have a complete
understanding of and point of fact both
sides should feel good about the outcome
and isn't that the definition of win-win
well kind of sort of
but it's how they feel about it more
than really what they got
so in a benevolent negotiation among
friends where are we gonna go to eat uh
where are we going on vacation what
route are we going to take
people really just want to be heard out
more than anything else which
operationally seems to be I don't
understand how it's going to make any
difference
makes all the difference in the world
and how what's the best way for somebody
to feel heard out well I'm going to
start out by telling you describing to
you not telling you
but describing to you
what my best guess is on your
perspective
because it's really calibrating me
actually finding out where your position
is
and the only way I can find out where
your position actually is
I'm gonna I'm gonna increase you telling
me if I start taking a guess at it first
because you're immediately right away
you you immediately going to tell me
either I'm right or I'm wrong you're
going to correct me correction
is um is a satisfying thing to do
and you're going to be much more candid
with me if you're correcting me than if
I'm asking you
so I'll and you'll feel good about
correcting me so it's gonna there's all
these great emotional lubricants to me
getting you to correct me so I'm going
to start out by saying like here's
here's what I think you're thinking
here's how I think you're approaching
this is what I think you're wanting out
of this out of this
not what you should be
but what you probably are based on your
perspective and that's going to
accelerate the conversation
exponentially like it's ridiculous how
much faster things are going to go and
then it becomes both an information
gathering and a report building process
simultaneously instead of separately
which is what makes this approach faster
even though it seems more indirect
so if we're getting ready to let's say
you're not going to take a car trip to
Calif to San Francisco from here
and I'm gonna say all right so my guess
is
you want to take the most direct route
because you hate wasting time
and you're probably going to say to me
no no no I want to go up the Pacific
Coast Highway because this beautiful
stretch of uh country like I realize
it's going to be a waste of time if we
go up the Pacific coast because we got
to jump off it at some point but I
really want to see the scenery
you would have I've taken a guess of
what you want and you're going to come
back real quick and correct me and then
maybe
I'm thinking time on the trip but I've
forgotten how beautiful it is to roll up
the coast
and so when you throw that out I'll be
like oh yeah
it is a beautiful ride and we might not
get another shot like who knows what's
going to happen so
yeah I know now now that we're having a
conversation I'd rather run up the
Pacific Coast Highway before we before
we go Inland and make the trip and
that's how we get to
um we collaborate for a bit a better
outcome maybe a better idea than what I
had in mind in the first place
I love that because what you just
described is hypothesis testing yes it's
the way scientists are training you know
many people don't know this but they
teach us in science not to ask questions
but to start with a question like you
know
how does how does the brain develop or
something and then you say a hypothesis
and you test hypotheses and you figure
out if they're right or wrong and that
takes you through a set of decision
trees and you eventually get it what you
hope is some core truth
um and then hopefully others arrive
there as well and you get a consensus so
I love the idea of hypothesis testing in
fact when you said uh take the most
direct route from where we are now in
Los Angeles to San Francisco I like to
take one-on-one not the five the five is
faster so I immediately think but I like
101. first of all there are a couple
really great taco and hamburger spots
along the way that I used to stop with
my bulldog and yeah also you get to see
the coast and it makes those extra two
hours completely worth it and so you're
exactly right in um in that
working through the decision tree
doesn't necessarily mean
um presuming that the the hypothesis is
right it sounds like you'd be equally
okay with the hypothesis being wrong
because really what you're trying to do
is just learn and in learning set up
this collaboration I love that a couple
of things first of all when you talk
about hypothesis and when when my son
Brandon was involved in a company he's
on he's out on his own now but he used
to always say hypothesis test your
hypothesis you always use that term
and then even now like we were talking
about it and you just said you knew some
hot dog and hamburger places I'd be like
holy cow
I didn't even know that yeah yeah I want
to check those places out so that's how
you discover new stuff in a conversation
I love it so um and also I'm sure people
are noting to not say the words win-win
When approaching any kind of negotiation
what do you think it is about those
little um catchphrases that that signal
lack of authenticity or trustworthiness
because you could imagine that somebody
you know I come to you and say you know
hey Chris like let's um I don't know
let's do some collaborative thing for
social media for podcast and um this is
gonna be a win-win for both of us now I
know to never say that with you but you
could imagine that somebody really means
that yeah but for you it sounds like
it's a flag that um they're trying to
pull one over it's it's uh it correlates
really strongly with the people that are
definitely trying to cut your throat and
I've had I've had him admit that to me
candidly amazing like I'll be
um I've experienced it like if somebody
throws win-win out early to me I'll say
all right I think I know where this is
going but let me explore it
and they'll say yeah you know this great
opportunity for you that's another tile
and we're going to put you in a room
with all these billionaires and there's
going to be all this opportunity for you
if you just come in and speak and you
know we don't have a budget well I've
gotten that one before yeah the famous
the famous uh the world will just work
out in your favor because magic because
it's going to work out in my favor right
yeah yeah exactly right I mean I've been
on the receiving end of those offers
many a time
um fascinating
conversely what sorts of openers
um do you think established the best
Rapport and um you know benevolent
discovery of a topic
well what I'm saying correlates real
strongly with people I want to do
business with if if they figured out
something that they know is valuable for
me and they've just done it
and they've just offered it like right
off the bat
no strings attached they found a way
to drop something on me that's valuable
they didn't approach me with their hand
out
they approached me with some sort of
generosity
I think a friend of mine Joe polish runs
this outfit called genius Network Joe I
believe he says life gives to the giver
um I Joe did a bunch of favors for me
before I ever joined
and he was trying to help me out and get
my book sold and he asked me to come in
and speak and he he'd done a he
emphasized my book on his podcast and
different conversations
and I you know I I finally paid the fee
to join because he had done so much for
me like there's not much Joe could ask
me for right now
because he's done so much for me that he
gets a blanket pretty much yes right
away whatever what do you want what do
you need because he's just generous
and the generosity approach universally
I'm seeing a lot of really successful
people that lead by generosity
and so if you start out
that you know if you if you give me a
five star review of the book on Amazon
no strings attached
or anything like that goes a long long
way to somebody who wants to establish a
long-term relationship a collaboration
when I first opened my laboratory in
2011 I had a technician at the time who
had been a technician for a lot of years
and there's this culture and science of
people borrowing things from
Laboratories and not giving them back or
breaking them these can be little things
like a you know small instrument or a
forceps
um but you know as a student or postdoc
these are the things that you covet like
a really nice pair of forceps it's like
a great thing you know you drop them
once they're not they're not good
anymore by the way it's like they're
they're to treat them with respect
surgical tools have to be treated with
respect these are very fine instruments
and people used to come by our lab all
the time and borrow stuff from us and
he'd always lend it out and I was like
what are you doing but anytime I went to
go borrow something he'd say Do not
borrow anything from anybody else
because then we're gonna owe them right
now everybody owes us everything and I
was like you're running up our budget
giving away these instruments they come
back with the forceps dented and stuff
and he said just trust me this is the
way to do it and I don't recall ever
never quote unquote cashing in on any of
that but he was exactly right when I
eventually decided to move institutions
we'd given away so much and we had asked
for so very little maybe nothing that
you know it's when you leave a place
typically there can be a little bad
blood and all we got was sorry to see
you go kind of stuff had it been me I
would have been in a kind of an exchange
of oh we asked for things we give things
you know it's kind of a neighborhood I
grew up in a neighborhood where you'd
borrow eggs or milk from the neighbor
remember those days uh I don't know if
people do that any longer
um but I think it falls well into what
you're describing that you know when
when you just do things for people
um out of goodness then you know sure
you sort of have a a history where you
could return to that they owe you but
there's also just something good about
just doing things out of goodness and
also not asking for so much
um and expecting people to provide that
so I I love that and I actually
um
I love providing good reviews for things
I like you know on the phone when um you
know the airline that we don't do this
anymore we book our own flights but
anytime I get help on the phone and you
know if it's really great help I'll say
how can I help and they'll say oh it
would mean a lot if you would send an
email to this to my business just saying
I I did a great job or something like
that and I actually really enjoy doing
that so um I love the points you're
making because they're very actionable
as many of you know I've been taking ag1
daily since 2012. so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring the podcast ag1 is a
vitamin mineral probiotic drink that's
designed to meet all of your
foundational nutrition needs now of
course I try to get enough servings of
vitamins and minerals through whole food
sources that include vegetables and
fruits every day but oftentimes I simply
can't get enough servings but with ag1
I'm sure to get enough vitamins and
minerals and the probiotics that I need
and it also contains adaptogens to help
buffer stress simply put I always feel
better when I take ag1 I have more focus
and energy and I sleep better and it
also happens to taste great for all
these reasons whenever I'm asked if you
could take Just One supplement what
would it be I answer ag1 if you'd like
to try ag1 go to drinkag1.com huberman
to claim a special offer they'll give
you five free travel packs plus a year
supply of vitamin D3 K2 again that's
drink ag1.com huberman
shifting slightly into the more let's
call them high friction negotiations or
the types of negotiations where there is
the potential for a truly bad outcome
right
um I know you've been asked this before
but some of our listeners are going to
be learning about you for the first time
do you recall of the many negotiations
that you did while in the FBI
any one particular negotiation that felt
like if this doesn't work out this is
really catastrophic
and would you be willing to share that
with us well um
I learned you know they tried to teach
this early on that not everything's
going to work out
and the second negotiation I had in the
Philippines uh the first one uh uh a
young man named Jeff Schilling was
grabbed by terrorist group uh Abu sayef
and he ended up walking away because we
still we stole the bad guys long enough
that we just you know sometimes
if you can slow it down you wait for
something good to fall out of the sky
and it will and that ended up happening
in that case and a bad guy ends up
calling the negotiator that I coached on
the phone after it was over
to basically tell them
that they still had a good relationship
it was nuts
um why does a bad guy call The
Negotiator that was responsible for him
losing everything
and say you know you did a good job
which is exactly what happened
so we roll into a case
um and I hadn't had anything go bad at
that point in time the very next case
said Burnham some Barrel case
uh by a different faction of the
terrorist group
13 months later ends up in
um
two or three remaining hostages shot
killed by Friendly Fire
uh on along the way
hostages have been executed America have
been executed early on and it was it was
a train wreck
and lots of people got killed all along
the way and just really ridiculous bad
things happening and that that was bad
all the way through
um so we learned you know learned a lot
from it
um went back and checked everything we
did
and we didn't do anything wrong that we
felt based on our strategy didn't didn't
miss anything and that was why I ended
up going uh collaborating with the guys
at Harvard because my reaction was if
this if we did everything we know how to
do and it wasn't enough that means we're
not smart enough we got to get better
and so that case taught me a lot about
the Dynamics that really happened on the
other side and
the difference between
you know whether or not people are
really on your side the US government
was not highly collaborative
uh the Philippine government was not
highly collaborative
that everybody wanted to get their pound
of flesh out of the other out of the
other side I mean just everything bad
that you can imagine early on when
Grandma sabero uh was murdered by the
Abu sayif it was a national holiday in
the Philippines
and the bad guys had a history of
killing people on national holidays
and we weren't from the Philippines and
we had no idea that that day was a
national holiday
and we showed up at uh Philippine
national police headquarters in Manila
and it was closed now we got it on I got
an ongoing hostage case with bad guys
threatening to kill hostages
and we show up at the gates and the
gates are closed and we're like what the
hell's going on here it was the national
holiday nobody's working today
I'm like
first of all nobody told us that
secondly I don't think the bad guys
really care that it's a national holiday
and nobody's working
our negotiators nowhere to be found
we got a we got a guy there that um uh
the previous negotiator we worked with
Philippine national police was not that
happy that they didn't have
him under complete control so they give
us a guy that will not tell us anything
until after he's told them so he's
having conversations with the bad guys
and we're actually hearing about him
second hand
he didn't show up that day and then and
of course that day
the bad guys announced they're going to
kill uh kill a hostage
and give it as a gift to the country of
the Philippines because it's a holiday
and then go oh by the way they like
doing this on holidays
and so
and and Grandma Sombrero ended up
getting his head cut off
with the because of all the warring
factions on our side of the table not
telling each other what the hell's going
on
so I had assumed at that point in time
that people would tell us the stuff we
need to know we didn't need to ask and
and after that I got like look there
ain't nothing here that I don't need to
know I don't if it's a holiday it's
coming up then you assume I know you got
to tell us
so really learned a lot about
collaboration on our side of the table
and also
the lack of collaboration on the other
side of the table just because we're a
mess doesn't mean they got their act
together and the bad guys didn't have
their act together and ultimately the
hostages
one of the reasons someone didn't come
out because internally they they had
double crossed each other
so learned a lot about what really
fundamental human nature Dynamics are on
teams and your team has not got its act
together and the other team does not
either so what can you do as a
communicator to make up for that really
learned a lot about that in that case I
had cases subsequent to that involving
Al Qaeda when Al Qaeda was killing
people on a regular basis
but we saw those coming and we did
everything we could do to keep the train
from smashing into US you see a train
coming down the tracks
you know it's coming down the tracks
and you do the best you can to derail it
and sometimes you can't
I've heard it said that
when people take somebody captive that
they either want their money
their body or their life or some
combination of those yeah that's
probably one of those three yeah that's
very true
and
as The Negotiator trying to rescue the
hostage is it important to identify
early on which of those three or which
all of those three
um thereafter like how serious they are
are they willing to actually kill the
hostage are they
um you know will they go for any amount
of money above
X number of dollars right right I'm
trying to figure out their threshold
right I mean because the person is on
the other side is gambling right they're
gambling their their freedom they're
gambling their
um reputation with whoever their
reputation matters to
um is it important to get into the
mindset of the person you're negotiating
with quickly
um using the hypothesis uh generating
method
um and if so uh could you give an
example of how that played out in in
your previous work yeah the um uh the
indicators are really there I mean once
you sort of uh lose your Illusions about
how you things how you think things
should play out
then the patterns of behavior are
generally pretty quick
uh and clear and just because you don't
like the patterns like with Al Qaeda we
recognize the patterns and
knowing what they are doesn't mean you
can change what they are and Al Qaeda in
2004's time frame was very clear about
killing people on deadline
and we had to recognize that
so there there becomes a pattern of
behavior and it's usually specificity in
what they say
and this is this is all this is all
human nature like if
if you're in a business negotiation and
they say you know we're gonna do
something horrible here you know we're
gonna walk out
you know that's fairly non-specific
and if they say look if we don't get
this by this specific deadline if we
don't get these specific things met by
this specific time
that's pretty specific that it's
specificity you're looking for it
I learned to look forward in kidnapping
negotiations we're working a case again
in the Philippines
and a bad guy say you know if uh if we
don't get a ransom for the sun 17 year
old boy at the time is kidnapped you
know you tell his father he's going to
lose an egg
and that's you've you've euphemism for
losing a child
and early on when that threat came
through on our side of the table
everybody's like oh my God they're going
to kill him you know this is really bad
we got to make sure the family can pay
the ransom I'm like no no no
it didn't it didn't say when it was
going to happen they didn't say how it's
going to happen
they didn't say who was going to do it
you know the basic specificity of who
what when and where like they left
themselves and out here a very clear out
and we never said we were going to do it
we never said when it was going to
happen we never said which child you
know what they're just trying to scare
you they're throwing out something back
I said we got we got plenty of time to
play with this
we gotta we gotta push this all the way
through the process into the end
now later on in that case
when the family tried to deliver a
ransom and it was screwed up by God
knows who
the bad guys came up back on the phone
and they said if we don't get paid
tomorrow your son dies
and I said all right now that's specific
and these guys sound like they mean it
and so we're going to have to make sure
this thing goes down tomorrow
or
that's the end of this kit
and at that point in time we allowed the
family
we were in a position to allow or
disallow
we were in a position to offer thoughts
and our thoughts were
they mean it now and you need to do
something
now or likely something bad is going to
happen and
now that they're this serious because
you always got to worry about what we
used to refer to as a double dip
do they take the money and then and they
come back and say no that was a down
payment that wasn't the ransom that was
just a down payment
you got to make sure you don't get
double dipped if you let the family pay
and you got to give me your honest
opinion as to whether or not they're
going to let the hostage go if you pay
now
and our our thoughts were you Pam
tomorrow your son's coming out and he
did
the double dip is a scary thing to hear
about
um at a much lower level meaning more
minor level
um people sometimes get shaken down
online you know like their password will
get taken there are people everywhere
who go for the click on this link you
know you get a text message you know
we've identified that your account has
you know been changed verify you click
on the link takes you someplace where
you put in your login and password and
boom it's gone and then they try and
sell it back to you typically through
cryptocurrency because it's not
traceable by the way those those
negotiations can be a lot of fun if you
let them
well I'm hoping that our discussion
about this now is going to save some
people uh the trouble of having their
their accounts hacked I've known people
who've had their accounts hacked and
these are some smart people but what's
interesting is that I've also observed
those situations where somebody gets to
the point where they say you know I'm
just going to give them what they want
and I I remember in this one particular
instance saying no no do not give them
the money because then they're just
going to say they want more there's no
there's no guarantee that they're going
to give you back what you want right and
why would they right if you think about
it why would they the money funnels in
and like they just can pivot and go to
the next thing so how do you
um gain confidence that you are likely
to be double dipped or not
um well first of all I got to find out
if you know if they're in a position to
carry out the threat or if they're in
any sort of legitimate position to begin
with you know for lack of a better term
it's Proof of Life
and there are a lot of people that are
trying to scam you but they don't really
have the ability to scam you
so you got to find out you know do some
confirmation do they do they have access
to your account do they do they have
your data they have your money do they
have it in a position are they just
trying to make you believe
that they have that position of
influence on you
um there are a lot of a lot of the bad
guys out there that are just rolling a
die styling for dollars if you will
and if they don't scam you when they
have no leverage on you they'll find
somebody else that'll give in so there's
a bit of you know authenticity or or are
they in a position to do it and um
the same rule applies in any negotiation
um the other side is going to give in
when they feel like they've gotten
everything they can
kidnappers I'd be asked by an ambassador
asked by an FBI Commander when's it is
going to be over when the bad guys feel
like they've gotten everything they
could not when they did
but when they felt like they did
so our job is just make them feel it
sooner
so you know how how hard you make it
innocently
on the other side everybody everybody
wants to feel like they did a they got a
good day's pay for a good day's work
so
if you let them feel like they're in
charge
and you make them work
by asking them innocent how and what
questions
which are very hard and fatiguing to
answer
then you're going to get to the point
where you're going to get a solid
outcome where you don't get double
dipped and they're going to be happy
that it's over because they felt like
they got everything they could it could
be your data could be your bank account
um could be anything
the other side is going to be satisfied
with the outcome when they feel like
they worked for it
and in business negotiations you're
selling your car
and some you put a price tag on your car
and a guy walks up to you and says I'll
give you full amount right now
what's your reaction
I should ask for more
um maybe I won't sell my car
you know every human interaction the
other side wants to feel like that they
earned what they got
and so the idea of
empathy and hostage negotiations is
really just to make them feel that
sooner
we're going to come back to empathy
because it's such a big and important
topic but I've heard it said before that
if somebody you don't know but maybe
also somebody you know places a real
sense of urgency on you know need the
money now or
um I need you to do something right away
or else not a threat of physical
violence but that any request for
Expediting something is a red flag yeah
that it's likely to be a scam
you know very seldom do you need to
click on the link within 24 hours right
I mean how could that possibly be right
that right but we but that's one way in
which people are exploited yep
um that some request comes in by phone
or by you know email or text or maybe
even person somebody says you know you
need to do this right now or else
something bad is going to happen capture
people's sense of urgency get them to
make a mistake and then they're they're
left reeling because that request for
something right now or else I think hits
a a fundamental nerve in US yeah you
know they want to help to be a rescuer
right so um is that a good rule of thumb
for people to keep in mind to to not I
think that's a great rule of thumb I
mean I I A friend of mine um somebody
got a hold of his phone number not that
long ago and um I was getting texts from
his number
so I'm like look man I got some real
problems look I need some money from you
now who's a friend a friend's number
and I remember when I first saw it
actually if when I first saw it I was
really busy and I felt bad that I didn't
get back to him that day
and then I didn't hear from him again
and so I thought well whatever it was
you worked it out
so a couple weeks later I get the text
again
you've got a real problem you got to get
back to me right now
so I'm I'm I decide if it's really my
buddy I am gonna help him right now I
gotta make sure it's really my buddy
and I said hey man you know uh you
didn't raise this at all last time I saw
you in Vegas because I'd seen him in
Vegas recently
and he's like yeah you know I was busy I
couldn't bring it up
and something like ours so there's no
direct confirmation or denial we had we
had breakfast together in Vegas
so then I shoot back I said like and man
I got to tell you something that was
such a crazy night and I still owe you
money from them so
you know that night when we were
gambling I I still owe you money I'm
happy to help
now it wasn't a crazy night it was
breakfast and I didn't know money
and his next response was like yeah
don't worry about it you know you can
make that up from from to me with this
so I'm like all right cool
so now I start making stuff up
and I said you know and when we were
with those strippers and that dog and
the clown and the pony I'll never get
over that and so now the guys what are
you talking about and I said by the way
and then I started throwing in some
stuff about his wife and his mother and
the guy got insulted and called me names
and stopped texting me and then I then I
sent all those text messages to the real
guy
including you know what I'd said about
his mother
and he texted me back he's got a great
sense of humor he says by the way my mom
does think you're attractive
oh man I think but I start I started it
all by just checking the source
if it was my friend I would have helped
him immediately
and I need to throw something at him
that's going to confirm that it's him
and then I'm there for him
but I'm also going to have put a little
bit of a curve in there that that if he
doesn't catch I know it's I know it's a
con
and then I'm gonna have fun with it
incredible knowledge that you know
people will hear this and they might
think oh you know that's never going to
happen to me but like I said I've known
family members and friends who they make
the mistake they take the bait of
clicking on the link and then now
they're getting the Shakedown
um actually a good friend of mine
said that her parents
called at some point her parents
probably in their late 70s now
um someone had called their house and
told them that their child this woman
had been
um
kidnapped right and that they needed to
send money right and that if they called
the police they'd kill her or harm her
in some way right so they started
sending money and they were afraid to
contact her and you can see like what a
bind a a loving parent would be in right
they obviously don't want to get this
child of theirs hurt and they obviously
are willing to do whatever it takes in
order to get them back turns out it was
total scam right because eventually
there was communication that made me
realize that their daughter was
perfectly okay and never even interacted
with kidnappers so those kinds of scams
happen pretty often I've had that happen
to a friend also yeah so the sense of
urgency should have been the first flag
that's a that's a great Point yeah
absolutely yeah and look look even if
they've got your loved one
the secondary issue is if you do what
they want are they going to let them go
which is actually a legitimate question
like if they really are bad guys one of
the things we learned in
hostage negotiation that I applied a
business negotiation
there are legitimate questions that it's
okay to ask
you're not being disrespectful you're
not pushing back
there's there are fair
you know to use the F-bomb Fair
legitimate questions that you can ask
under any circumstances which is
basically you know if I comply
is this going to work out the way that
you're articulating it
anything that adds communication into it
which gives you more information
to find out what the ultimate outcome
looks like
even in kidnappings
how do you know that how do you know
that if you pay they're going to let
them go
that's a legitimate question
there are examples somewhere in between
you know getting your Instagram account
hacked your bank account hacked and you
God forbid your child kidnapped
for instance there's a whole
practice within the legal profession of
probing to see whether or not somebody
is going to give up money to avoid a
lawsuit for instance right this is a
actually a lawyer friend of mine
recently described their job very well
he said in his words first person he
said I scare people for money
the operative word being scare people
it's being an ant being honest yeah he's
being very honest he scares people for
money and he's very good at it and um
and he understands how other people
scare people for money and he works both
sides you know and uh plaintiff or
defense type situations
but you know it made me realize that you
know a lot of the legal profession is
not okay the lawsuit slid across the
table it's the okay here's what the
lawsuit would look like here are all the
statutes that potentially were were
violated and then there's a probe of
like what somebody's finances are and
you know how much they're willing to pay
and do they have liability insurance do
they have an umbrella policy all the
sorts of things that are that are really
it's not necessarily an illegal
Shakedown but it's
you know a probing as to whether or not
you know there's it's worth the effort
diagnosing the other side's ability to
pay you're right and so that happens
really often I can give a specific
example where
um somebody had a incident at a dog park
where their dog
um
allegedly ran into somebody maybe
charged at somebody you know dog park
people are standing around and the
person moved and and apparently injured
their knee
but rather than
sue the owner of the dog what they
typically do is deliver some set of
documents that say you know
I was injured your dog was responsible
for this
um and
if you don't settle up for X number of
dollars you're going to be sued for
usually an exorbitant amount above that
right right and then there's this
question that the the lawyers have to
figure out like is it puffery right are
they saying I'm going to sue you for
four million dollars is there any basis
for that and good lawyers will say
that's puffery they're they're trying to
scare you with a big number but a lot of
people see that number and go oh my
goodness what do they want you know what
like I don't even know if they were
injured if they were that's terrible I'd
want that taken care of if my dog's
responsible I'd want that taken care of
but what what do they need in order to
make this this go away right and that
happens millions of times a day
throughout the country and a good
portion of those probably happen here in
California because there's a that's kind
of the way the legal system is arranged
right so this is not somebody
um you know it could be somebody
manipulating the law it could also be
somebody who's being entirely honest
about their experience of being injured
by somebody else's dog
so under those conditions I mean it
sounds like the same set of rules apply
you want to know how serious they are
do they have a case so to speak that's
the work of the lawyers but in assessing
how serious somebody is you said
you it's fair you called it the f word I
like that I'll never forget that it just
ask a fair question like like how much
money do you think you deserve or
um is that would that be a good example
of a very direct question uh or is it
um How likely are you to walk away if we
don't give you the money like you know
is there I mean because I can imagine
there's all sorts of reasons why people
would be dishonest about about answering
those questions well and then uh how
much money do you think you could
deserve uh you deserve is is a really
good question not necessarily
what the answer is but how they answer
it
you're going to get how quickly they
fire back and whether or not they stop
and think about it
how and what questions typically
are best to judge these other side's
reaction and the answer is secondary
because the how or what question causes
what we would refer to as deep thinking
slow thinking Danny Kahneman
behavioral economics
thinking fast and slow slow thinking is
in-depth thinking
you ask a how or what question to make
the other side think first
and judge their reaction to how they
think about it
and do they actually do they actually
think about it or do they fire right
back at you that gives you a clearer
picture of who you're dealing with where
the outcome is going to go how much
money do you think that you deserve if
they immediately you know 10 million
dollars
all right so this is I got a Shakedown
artist on the other side
or they say all right if they stop and
think about it and they give you a
thoughtful answer that's a completely
different person on the other side
you're asking a question to get a to
diagnose how they respond first
the answer is second
and sometimes I if it's a Cutthroat on
the other side I'm going to start
peppering them with how and what
questions
just to wear them out
that's passive aggression if I if I got
a Cutthroat aggressor on the other side
I'm going to drop into passive
aggressive
Behavior
to slow him down and where I'm at
um one of my hostage negotiation Heroes
a guy named Johnny Pico
was John Domenico Pico not not Johnny
like Johnny Rockets Italian Johnny John
Domenico
got all the Western hostages out of
Beirut in the mid 80s
wrote a book called Man Without a Gun
negotiated in person face to face with
Hezbollah the only guy that ever did
that got everybody out
and in his book he wrote one of the
great secrets to negotiation is learning
how to exhaust the other side
and when you've got a really dangerous
adversary on the other side of the table
you don't go nose to nose you don't
argue you don't you're not combative you
wear them out
exhaust them
and if you get somebody really combative
or Cutthroat on the other side
start peppering them with how and what
questions
because to even think about the answer
it tires them out
and it's passive aggressive and it's
deferential and it really works
so if the person on the opposite side of
a
High friction negotiation is aggressive
the goal is to slow things down
fatigue them yeah
and get them to just either relent or to
reveal something that's that's a
loophole yeah right yeah if if I have to
make the deal
then I'm gonna wear them out
I'd like to take a quick break and
acknowledge our sponsor inside tracker
inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
meet your health goals I'm a big
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that many of
the factors that impact your immediate
and long-term Health can only be
analyzed from a quality blood test
however with a lot of blood tests out
there you get information back about
blood lipids about hormones and so on
but you don't know what to do with that
information with inside tracker they
have a personalized platform that makes
it very easy to understand your data
that is to understand what those lipids
what those hormone levels etc mean and
behavioral supplement nutrition and
other protocols to adjust those numbers
to bring them into the ranges that are
ideal for your immediate and long-term
Health right now inside tracker is
conducting a giveaway valued at six
thousand dollars this giveaway includes
a full year of inside tracker tests a
consultation with a registered dietitian
and a hydro indoor rowing machine to
learn more about inside tracker and to
enter this zero cost giveaway go to
fitnessfuelslongevity.com to enter
that's
I'm interested in drilling a little bit
further into this process of wearing
them down and the passive aggressive way
of
reducing The aggressors Stance and I
want to highlight for people that you
know what we're talking about here isn't
you know manipulation to extract
something we're actually talking about
the reverse we're talking about a bad
actor who's aggressive and trying to
um de-fang that bad actor yeah yeah what
is that process of wearing them down
look like or sound like could you give
us a couple of examples of let's say I'm
the bad actor we could play this game I
won't be very good at this
um and I am saying look
I want
X number of dollars by at this date
or you're not going to get what you want
they're gonna die
or disappear
it's that simple and I'm you know a
Stonewall kind of approach
what is the approach that you take to
wear that person down
well what what a they're going to be how
questions that are mostly how and what
and they're going to be legitimate
questions
which is
how do I know you're going to follow
through
what does that look like
like if I do what you want
how do I know you're going to follow
through
so get them to talk about the
alternative okay so if you were to well
if you deliver by that date
I'm gonna pass them to you
without fail like if they're just
getting kind of brief answers where the
person is just again this kind of like
rigid Stonewall approach
yeah well and so there's a phrase that
we use all the time Vision drives
decision
so if if you're really going to comply
if I if I give in and when I said how do
I know you're gonna you're gonna follow
through I'm not talking about the threat
I'm not trying to get you to clarify the
threat
I'm trying to get you to clarify what
implementation looks like
so I need to know I'm based on your
reaction to that
if you plan on following through if I
comply
you will already have that in your head
or be open to it Vision drives decision
you've thought it through in advance
what does letting the hostages go look
like
if you do if you have no intention of
ever released releasing a hostage if I
follow through
then you're not going to be able to
answer the question or and you're
probably going to throw it back on me
really quickly
and so then now I know like all right so
you got no plans on complying
if I give in you're not going to comply
so I but you still want the money
then I'm gonna ask well
how am I supposed to pay you if you
don't have any plans for compliance
and if you're willing to entertain a
conversation about what compliance looks
like
it was a kidnapping
that my unit worked just before I was in
it in Venezuela
where they weren't entirely sure that
the bad guys were gonna the farc I think
had had the hostage
they agreed on an exchange point to let
the hostage go that was
some distance from where they had a
pretty good idea the hostage was being
held
so they figure they're not going to drag
the hostage all the way to this River
Crossing if they're not going to let
them go it's just too much effort
and then it was one of the few times
there was going to be a simult
theoretically a simultaneous exchange
but they're going to have to send the
money
across the river before the hostage was
let go
so if we agree to this all right so
they're not going to drag this this guy
all the way to this River Crossing
they don't plan on letting them go
and if it's a long way to drag them and
they got their money do they want to
drag them back
like even if they're ambivalent once
they get there if they've gone through
all the effort to get to the meeting
location and the hostage is there
we've now just increased the chances
significantly they're going to go ahead
and comply because it's a pain in the
neck to take them back
this is all human nature stuff human
nature investment
how do you get them to engage in actions
and behaviors
and then verbal commitments that
actually mean something to them when I
was working kidnappings
the very last thing we always have the
family get the bad guys to say it last
not first but last
we'd actually get a verbal promise to
let them go
again at the end because we've been
talking to them long enough at this
point in time we got a pretty good idea
what they sound like when they're lying
and what they sound like when they tell
them the truth
if somebody tells the truth they pretty
much tend to tell the truth the same way
every time if
they tell the truth
you talk to somebody long enough you got
a line on do they ever tell the truth
and if they do what does it sound like
people lie 20 ways
they tell the truth one way
so we've been coaching the negotiations
with the kidnappers long enough that we
know what they sound like when they tell
the truth so when they ask at the very
end
if we if we paid you promise to let them
go
it's not that the answer but how they
answered it
and that that'll be the last thing to
seal the deal you know how do you
continually stack the odds in your favor
for implementation do you have a bodily
like a somatic sensor for lying uh the
reason I ask is years ago I had the
experience of knowing somebody and uh
they turned out to be a generally good
person but I sensed early on
that something was like off I couldn't
relax around them right I just couldn't
relax around them and and I could not
tell you why but it was as if my
I couldn't even identify the
neuroanatomy of it you might say it was
the vagus nerve or something but I teach
in her anatomy and I can't point to one
pathway in the body there was something
about my autonomic response that would
just start cranking up when I was around
them like something is off something is
off something else and I and I kid you
not five years later five years later I
discovered
a series of lies that all ratcheted
together that were actually pretty
meaningless in the total context of
things but I remember thinking at that
moment oh my goodness like my my system
knew
like new
and you know for all my knowledge of
Neuroscience I can't tell you to this
day like what it was in in the
in my biology but it had something to do
with my bodily response it wasn't just a
thought like that doesn't quite add up
or I feel like I'm getting the run
around or or this it was it was a
physical sensation
are you familiar with that experience
yeah well it's a little bit uh what you
guys and your colleagues are still
discovering the science behind the gut
and what we're actually teaching you
know my company now we're teaching
people learn the difference between your
gut and your amygdala for lack of a
better time your fear centers
and know which one is which and listen
to your gut your gut is ridiculously
accurate now where where does that
information come from
one of your podcasts recently I was
listening to who were talking about Olaf
Factory juice right the smells like I
never thought of that of course
you know yeah they're the the
um uh was a term for the um the the
molecules that you're putting off that
that oh pheromones oh pheromones
gonna get kicked out like of course and
that's why some of the great
investigators I knew would say I can
just smell it I can smell it
so what all is feeding your gut and what
what are the senses
that the science hasn't yet discovered
you know you can't you can't make me
believe I'll I will never believe that
the life force stops at the surface of
our skin that there's energy and that we
can pick up on the energy I mean our gut
is being fed by all these different
inputs that we're aware of
or that we have yet to be made aware of
that tonal voice doesn't match their
their words the the head tilt you've got
a super computer in your brain your gut
is incredible if you could listen to it
instead of your Fierce centers and as
soon as you start listening to your gut
you can't explain it at the time but you
gotta you got a bad feeling in your gut
and later on then you saw it all it all
came together where your brain was
picking up these cues
your your brain was probably when you're
in their presence there's got to be an
odor somebody gives off when they're
when they're intentionally deceiving
you don't you didn't know that that was
a smile and maybe you you couldn't have
consciously smelled it but you're still
picking it up so
long answer to I'm a very big believer
in in the gut I think there's science
that we know and yet to discover that
tells us that the gut is just
ridiculously accurate if we listen to it
instead of our fear centers
I completely agree that there are
energetic exchanges that Neuroscience
can't yet explain the field of
Neuroscience that is is starting to
explore some of these things
um there's basically uh three Apex
journals the most competitive journals
to publish in science nature and cell
and I only mentioned that because there
was a series of Articles written in
Science magazine about Magneto reception
in humans you know the idea that humans
can detect magnetic fields sounds like
quackery right Turtles can detect
magnetic fields they migrate by them
actually long distances but the idea is
that humans can't do that and yet there
are some well-controlled studies where
people have to guess about the
orientation of a magnetic field and they
do it better than chance not everyone
can do it but some can do it better than
chance in a way that cannot be predicted
by anything else except some inherent
form of magnetoreception in their
nervous system so there are capabilities
of the nervous system that are starting
to be revealed for which we don't have a
lot of evidence but there's enough
evidence to suggest that these things
are really happening
um the other example which you might
find interesting is a little bit uh more
a little less esoteric but there's a
beautiful paper published in one of the
cell press journals a couple of years
ago showing that when people listen to
the same story
the distance between their Heartbeats
tends to be very similar now it doesn't
mean that their exact heart rates are
similar but if you look at the distance
between their heartbeats they all
entrained to the same Rhythm the same
song and get this they're in completely
separate rooms these experiments are
being done on completely separate days
and yet if I were to line up just you
know the distance between the the
heartbeats for you they would line up
like a set of columns wow for dozens of
individuals listening to the same story
so you know clearly there's a passage of
energy from things we hear and things we
see that goes into our nervous system at
a level that's below our conscious
detection here's the last thing I'll say
about this we have a series on Mental
Health coming out not Mental Illness but
mental health
um by the uh I think to be among the
very finest psychiatrists in the world
Dr Paul Conte and he said you know we
all think that the forebrain is the
super computer right he said no
the subconscious is the super yeah yeah
that's where the real knowledge
processing is happening that's the
iceberg below the surface where all the
real heavy lifting has taken place and
that people who learn to tap into the
subconscious
can learn to use that information in
very meaningful ways and I think that's
what you're describing he's been on with
you before right he has to talk about
trauma in particular and he was on Lex
Friedman's podcast as well the series
that we're doing with him is not about
trauma per se it's really about the
subconscious and the self I think you'll
find this series really interesting yeah
and it has a number of very practical
questions that one can ask themselves
about their subconscious and and kind of
work the process of Psychiatry we're
excited to release that series but it um
because I don't know of anything like it
that's been put out there into the
public but but I was so um
pleasantly surprised to hear him say you
know we all hear that the the forebrain
is the super computer it's what drove
our Evolution he's like no no no
it's the it's the subconscious that's
where our real wisdom resides and the
forebrain is just the implementation
device so it's uh you know uh how we can
convince ourselves that that we're in
charge right yeah I mean I can't think
of a time that my gut told me a and it
turned out to be B more often than not
though I've suppressed my response right
I override it thinking I think I made
the mistake that you guys train your
negotiators to avoid which is I thought
well this is making me anxious and the
anxiety must be like me like this must
be my fault or I'm not able to call
myself in this situation
um not sleeping well Etc and um and
therefore like this much must represent
some deficiency on my part and then um
and Lord knows as your shirt points out
I'm I'm a very flawed person I have many
flaws I always say I have 3 000 pet
peeves and at least as many flaws to
match those that piece I wonder when at
least relationship but um
the point being that I think our bodies
really do know they know yeah yeah yeah
yeah I would agree so when you're doing
negotiations and you're hearing
somebody's voice on the phone there are
a lot of cues when you're face to face
there are additional cues there's their
face and then of course if the
negotiations are being done by text over
a computer or a phone it's a very
diminished environment for information
so maybe we could talk about each of
those because we live in those
Landscapes if we're face to face and
we're negotiating
um you're listening of course to what I
want what I'm insisting on you're
working that process from your your side
what are you paying attention to
visually
it's more are things in alignment
there's Layman's data you know the words
the way it said and look on people's
face and how are they weighed and how
they play out there's a ratio out there
that varying scientific 738 55 7 words
38 delivery 55 body language people
won't argue about it all the time
whether or not that's accurate
as a rule of thumb we throw that out
there but I tell people the most
important issue is do they line up
so
I'm not going to look for like when do
you raise your eyebrow or when do you
look up into the left
I'm really just going to try to get a
gut feeling whether or not I think these
things are lining up
whether they're in alignment whether
they're out of line
and then I'm going to be real careful
about
what meaning I assigned to that you know
uh affective cues
changes in your tone of voice
changes in your movement
and that's one of the reasons why we
don't teach reading people's body
language
because it's completely contextual to
you and the moment
so I if I convince myself that
you know a raise of the eyebrow means
this
it's out of context
I was in a negotiation once where I
threw out a figure to somebody and I
some kind of look off to the side and
look back
and accepted my offer
and I made the mistake of not saying to
them the appropriate thing for me to say
at the time would have been
seems like something just crossed your
mind
because you only completely true
observation if they look to the side and
look back something crossed their mind
now I read it at the moment of saying
that they had more money
foreign
they were stretched to the Limit
the look of hesitation
didn't mean that they were holding stuff
they were holding stuff back but I read
it wrong
and I didn't bother to check on the
affective cue that I saw
one of my babbling about what I'm
babbling about is
if we're in a negotiation and whether or
not I'm listening to your tone of voice
or watching your body language or your
words
if I see you shift at all
I should pay attention that there was a
shift in your affected Behavior
but I need to find out what was behind
it as opposed to making an assumption as
to what it meant so yeah I'm going to
watch I'm going to get my gut feeling
and I'm going to say
sounds like there's some hesitation or
it looks like something just crossed
your mind
or even if I can't attribute it to
specific affective move
I might say
it feels like there's something in the
way here
that's me listening to my gut
all throughout an observation on
whatever any of those might be
just to go back over the ground a little
bit and double check because the other
thing about negotiating in person
is you're going to give me more
information
physically than I can actually process
and if you say something that's thought
provoking
I'll stop and think about it and while
I'm stopping and thinking about what you
just said I'm missing all your cues
so all the skills that we teach the
labels the mirrors
the open-ended questions which seem like
we're going back and plowing the ground
again we are because I didn't pick up
all the information the first time
there's just more than I can get
and so I need to go back over it a
couple of times with you
just so I get it right
without making you feel interrogated you
actually feel heard
and you actually get to go back over it
again so it becomes what seems to be an
inefficient process but it's actually me
just double checking my information
so if we're face to face I'm gonna I'm
gonna ask you to repeat but I'm not
gonna say would you please repeat that
I'm going to get you to repeat without
asking you to repeat
is the same true in online or text
Communications the same thing is true
the the problem with online and text is
people try to bundle everything into one
communication
the best analogy I can think of is if
you're playing chess by text would you
put seven moves in your in your text
no you'd only put one move in
so only try to get one point across in a
text don't explain don't throw a whole
bunch of stuff in text or emails
they're all almost always too long
and it's going to come off as cold
so do what you can to soften soften it
um
there's a documentary film that's been
done on my company called tactical
empathy
nicknanton uh 122 23 Emmys
the filmmaker dnf DNA films it was
finished last year it's not out yet
for a variety of reasons we haven't put
it up
so that we screen the thing in Vegas
last year
I see it I love it
I'm not a good judge of a film about me
I'm going to love it no matter what it's
about me
but I tell Nick that night oh man I love
it this is great
two days later I find out I realize
there's a huge problem
I've already told them it's okay
so I gotta get him I gotta I'm gonna
text him and then I'm gonna call him and
we got to fix it now it's a Sunday
text message
I sent him a two-line text
it's now bad time to talk
I get something you don't want to hear
two lines
now what were my other options I could
have called him Nick and I got a great
relationship I call him
if he's in a position to pick up the
phone doesn't matter what he's doing
he's going to answer the phone
he was in the middle of a zoom call if
I'd have called he'd have picked up
during the zoom call and both
conversations would have been bad
he immediately fires back to me I'm in
the middle of a zoom call
I'll call you in a half an hour
he already knows he ain't gonna like
what he's going to hear I'm prepping him
for bad news
get him on the phone
like look I know what I said
we got a problem we got to get Derek on
camera Derek is a guy in my in my team
and I I'm shocked that I haven't made
him part of the documentary this is
going to be incomplete without dare we
got to get Derek on on film we can't
show this to anybody else until we get
him on film and make a part of it
immediately he's in problem solving mode
he goes okay I got to get a crew to
Derek or get Derek to a crew
I need to know when we can do that I
need to we gotta we got another showing
of the film scheduled in La less than a
month away
he says I got to get Derek on camera and
we got to edit it it's going to take
three weeks of editing I said I'll get
you access to Derek's camera he goes
done or there's calendar he says done
it's done
we go through this whole conversation in
less than 10 minutes
now think of the normal negotiation
hey Nick how are you what's going on
today are you in a good mood hey hey hey
how the kids doing all this time wasting
conversation
if I'd have set him up with that normal
he would also he he could have
legitimately said are you out of your
mind
we've been working on this for a year
you didn't bring this up in a year
not only that you already told me two
days ago at the at the showing in in
Vegas that you loved it and now uh a
year year and a half into this project
you're bringing up all these new
problems that would have been the normal
negotiation
but since I since we got a highly
collaborative relationship
I two line text we're done in 10 minutes
now since Nick's a very generous guy
when he gets done and he says by the way
you understand how much this is going to
cost me it's just three weeks of editing
this is three hours of shooting and
three weeks of editing
I go yeah he goes but I'm happy to do it
calls me back the next day
he's got a favorite asking me
you got it doesn't matter what it is
because we'd gone through what would
have been a very complicated negotiation
that started on taxed
and I sent him a two-line text on a
Sunday
and we got to solve that fast
so if I understand correctly by setting
the context in a very direct and
succinct way right
he goes into it in a problem-solving
mode with you whereas if you do the um
the tour of all the things that are
going well in life yeah yeah the sort of
the um
we'll keep this uh PG you know the the
um the mud sandwich approach you know
you know they teach you that you know
when you get a laboratory you know most
scientists have no skill running a
business right you get a laboratory all
you've done is experiments and then
suddenly you're in charge of people
managing budgets and all this stuff I
mean I mean most scientists
99 of scientists are completely
unqualified to do the job they do at the
level of running a laboratory when they
start you learn it on the job and
eventually you end up having to let
somebody go
and they'll and so the typical thing
they teach you in these online training
things is you tell somebody something
nice then you give them the bad news and
then you tell something them something
nice on exit right that's kind of the
the mud so to speak sandwich right all
right
um
this is not that what you're talking
about is saying hey
this is the problem you're not going to
like the problem or there is a problem
you're not going to like it so that they
show up with the context of solving a
problem as opposed to giving them the
tour of all the things that are going
well and then the problem is really in
contrast to that and then it's like uh
you know so so you what I love about
what you're describing is it's
it's just it's direct it's honest you're
not doing the uh the tour of the garden
before you take them down to the um to
the septic tank
it's what I would call the difference
between being blunt and being a straight
shooter
a straight shooter tells you the truth
they just tell it in a way that lands
Softly
let's talk about
breakups
business breakups romantic breakups
right
you breaking up with me no
no no
um but thanks for the hypothesis test No
in fact in fact I'm enjoying this
conversation so much as I always do I'm
learning a ton from you that um if
anything I'd like to expand and deepen
our relationship Chris
there you got a lot of knowledge out of
me
um platonic and and professional but
expansive
um
what is the process of ending a
relationship and again this could be a
romantic relationship could be business
relationship it could be employer
employee could be
individuals could be telling a whole
group or an entire group telling an
individual you know
the reason I raise this as a particular
example is that I'm assuming that
both sides don't want the same thing one
side wants to continue the other side
wants to end
right
um I'll avoid the use of the word
win-win
or the words win-win excuse me
and just ask is there a way to have that
conversation in any of the contexts I
just mentioned
in uh as you so beautifully described it
as straight shooter manner where it's
direct it's honest but it lands soft
because what we're talking about here is
feelings of rejection and nobody likes
feeling rejected I don't know anybody
that likes being fired even from jobs
they don't like
people's egos suffer right
so is there a maybe a more specific way
of asking the question is is there a way
to encourage the person getting the bad
news to get their ego out of the way and
see that
if both parties don't want it it's best
for everybody involved
I almost want to say no uh but first
what are the caveats most of the time
when people are struggling with this
they're not trying to save the other
side they're trying to save themselves
so who you really trying to save
by postponing its softening it you know
trying to act like
um uh it's it's something that it's not
like they're I don't know that anybody
has ever been fired that didn't have a
sense that it was coming the person that
was getting ready to fire him opens up
by saying how are you
and they know how the other person is
and a person getting ready to get fired
has got some gut instinct that things
are going wrong like you said the gut's
very powerful
so you gotta you gotta lower the boom as
quickly as you can but also as gently as
you can
I was involved in a non-profit a number
of years ago uh affiliated with church
and we're trying struggling with whether
or not to let the executive director go
I go to the minister of the Church
Norman Vincent peels Protege a guy named
Arthur calliandro one of the best human
beings I've ever met in my life
phenomenal guy
and I'm struggling with I thought firing
letting this woman go was going to be
bad and I thought Arthur was going to
counsel me a way out and he looked at me
and he said
you know there's there's no gentle way
to cut somebody's head off
and I thought
yeah the Humane thing here is how do you
to
bring it to conclusion as quickly as
possible because there's no humane way
to cut somebody's head off there's no
humane way
and to terminate the relationship now
what are the caveats maybe there are
first caveat if you're going to fire
somebody never fire somebody on a Friday
fry them on a Monday
find them on a Monday they got a work
week to work their way out of it you
find them on a Friday they get a weekend
to be miserable and feel horrible and
they can't do anything about it
caught off guard or not on a Monday
they can pick themselves up they can
start looking for a new job no matter
who you are
fire them on a Friday they can't start
looking for a new job on a Saturday it's
two days of misery so yeah if you're
gonna fire somebody fire them on a
Monday not on a Friday
if you got bad news to give somebody
warn them it's coming
the um
people are ridiculously resilient to
pain if worn
and then
that you lower the boom you're not going
to like what I have to say it's going to
be heartbreaking you're going to hate me
hesitate
no more than three seconds
they got their guard up let them have
the bad news
that's the humane way to cut somebody's
head off don't make don't linger
don't make them think that how are the
kids how are you I care about you you're
a great human being none of the stuff at
the beginning
warning bad news is coming and hit him
with the bad news
rip the Band-Aid off
the pain is not if you try to rip the
Band-Aid off slowly that's excruciating
you're trying to save yourself
so if you've got to terminate a
relationship regardless of what it is
the quicker it you do it the less
painless it is The Sooner people can
move on
stop trying to save yourself
realize how human beings handle pain
if anything human beings are incredibly
resilient if given the opportunity to
brace themselves first
I agree
thank you for that
there's a concept that a lot of people
haven't heard of and I'm confident in
saying that because I hadn't heard of it
until recently despite spending a lot of
time in the literature around dopamine
and motivation and it's a term from
psychology that is being used a little
bit more now
um and it's ego depletion yeah it's an
interesting concept and I've been
wanting to run this by you for a while
but I saved it for our discussion today
it turns out ego depletion is a lot like
decision fatigue
um you know we've all heard the Steve
Jobs thing you know he wore a black
turtleneck every day because it you know
he didn't have to make that decision so
he had more energy to make other
decisions I've been accused of doing the
same because of my black long sleeve
shirts but there's a whole other reason
for that that um some people might know
but anyway it's unimportant
in the moment
um but ego depletion is a little bit
different than decision fatigue or
decision budget the idea with ego
depletion is pretty simple it's that the
molecule dopamine does many things in
the brain but one of the things that it
absolutely does is it holds us to goal
directed Behavior that's associated with
a sense of self like I want to
accomplish this I want to get to that
and the whole notion of ego depletion
involves the the idea and this has been
a data substantiated observation that
when people have to fight to be right
or to defend their position
for a period of time eventually that
depletes and it seems to be at least in
part dopamine mediated because
defending one's position takes work
right you earlier you talked about
running somebody down you know
um wearing them out and I wonder as I
just throw this concept out to you a
cold here whether or not that calls to
mind any examples from your work where
you felt like okay like this person
could really hold
but if I just kept pressing eventually
they tilt right you know and it's
different than the kind of fatigue that
comes from a conversation that starts at
three in the afternoon and ends at 2 30
in the morning we've all been there
right I've been in those conversations
usually they're not very pleasant and at
three in the morning everyone's peeling
apart you just I've learned over the
years you know like you clip it at 9 30
and you try and shift right right you
know one of the worst pieces of advice
I've ever heard
um is you'd never go to sleep angry it's
like no actually uh actually get sleep
wake up and then revisit the problem if
the situation allows that's my uh that's
my uh yeah
um trying to stay up all night trying to
work something out it's just counter
biology so ego depletion
um I have a feeling a lot of what you
did in your profession was
um running down their dopamine to the
point where then they are operating from
a different place where they're not
defending the ego they're actually
thinking more practically about the
whole situation does it have any kind of
texture of meaning to you yeah no I
would I would agree and I would draw the
distinction
uh first of all in hostage negotiation
there's there's two kind of Hostage
takings
um if there's a demand
um and it's going to be contained and
uncontained which is just literal
definition contained as bad guys in a
bank like at the Chase Bank in Brooklyn
way back when you got them surrounded
they can't get away
and uncontained as a kidnapping you
don't know where they are uncontained
unknown location
we're going to try to get our way in a
contained situation
probably by ego depletion wearing them
out get them to the point where they
just I just they're just going to give
in because they're tired
because they're going to come out we're
going to put handcuffs on them
um
which means
that if the ego gets recharged
they're going to go back in there think
they're going to think back over the
deal
so wearing somebody out in a business
negotiation it's basically uncontained
because even if you come to an agreement
there's a whole implementation phase
they're going to you did you did you get
the agreement because you warm up
because they get tired
because he just gave in at some point in
time they're going to get recharged and
they're going to get recharged while
you're in implementation
so they're either going to not going to
follow the terms of the deal
or it's the slightest opportunity
they're going to deviate
and so yeah I think Eagle depletion is
is a real thing and it's a bad way
to get a business deal that's going to
stick
because they rest and then they come
back yeah a different person yeah yeah
they're going to be recharged their ego
is going to be
recharged and if you get the if you got
the agreement based on a depletion of
the ego that battery is going to get
charged back up again whether it's a
business deal whether it's a personal
negotiation
you know you have a disagreement with
your significant other and you you
follow that bad advice don't go to bed
angry
and so you stay up till three in the
morning and you think you come to a
resolution everybody gets a good night's
sleep the next day they feel completely
differently about what they said the
night before yeah I might have heard of
that happening once or twice it's not in
a movie right yeah I saw it in a movie
like a friend explained that situation
to me
um earlier you mentioned
approaching a conversation in a playful
way right like all right you know this
might even be life or death but let's
play this like a game because you can
see more opportunities now we know that
when we are relaxed we see the big
picture when we're tense everything
Narrows there's a tunnel vision tunnel
thinking tunnel everything we lose
access to the full tool kit so
you obviously take really good care of
yourself you're fit you're in shape you
always seem calm I'm sure you have your
moments like anybody else but
um
what are some of the things that
good negotiators do all the time
so that when the bell goes off and they
have to respond
they are ready and the reason I ask this
is because you know we've been talking
about negotiations in kind of a vacuum
like it's happening and then how does
one handle it but like any athlete like
any teacher like any parent like any kid
everybody has to be ready for real life
circumstances and we don't always get
the warning
we don't get the memo that it's
happening in two weeks and sometimes the
conversations around courtroom drama or
the big day you know it implies that we
we get the warning but more often than
not it's a phone call or a text and it
comes in and boom it just hits us and
suddenly we are in negotiations and we
didn't get time to prepare right so
maybe we could talk about readiness
and then we could talk about again like
maybe this sounds trivial to you but for
me I'd be very curious to know whether
or not you have any practices of
stilling yourself what those look like
um what you've seen other people use to
to be able to get themselves into the
moment of being able to show up their
best self yeah well um Readiness small
space practice for high stakes results
like I will occasionally find myself in
the middle of a negotiation that I
didn't expect
if I've been throwing out stuff on a
regular basis on my way during the day
verbal observations what we refer to as
labels because the label seems like
something just crossed your mind
is a label in the middle of a
negotiation when I see you hesitate or
look to the side
how do I get ready for that you know I'm
I'm on my way over here to this
interview
um I'm both talking to my Lyft driver
the whole way getting them to talk
also being careful about not
tapping the gas tank out completely so
that I'm fatigued when I get here
like I talk I talk about the Lyft
drivers on a regular basis
I um
interactions TSA guys in the airport
I'll throw a label at them seems like a
tough day tough day
seems like you're in a good mood
and whether right or wrong I'm getting
in I'm trying to stay loose I'm trying
to keep the mental muscles limber
and it just becomes a bit of a habit on
a regular basis occasionally I'll throw
something out now I'm talking about Lyft
drivers
like if I'm in a bad mood I I get into a
lift couple of weeks ago on my way home
Lyft driver is not helpful I mean I'm
coming out of the airport I'm struggling
my bags not lifting a finger it doesn't
open up the rear I gotta open up the
rear of the vehicle myself I got to load
the bags everything I get in and he's
just seething
unhappiness
now I know that if I say what do you
love about what you do for a living
I immediately trigger what Tony Robbins
would call a state change
and I'm annoyed at this guy and you know
our pheromones
are combative
but I'm thinking like I just I just
don't need this and so I go what do you
love about driving for left
this guy proceeds to unload on me on all
his personal struggles
that I feel like a complete jerk for
being angry with him at everything that
he's going through
and I'm just trying to get myself out of
bed out of a bad mood and to keep from
sending him a really negative vibe the
whole way so that he doesn't drive
45 miles an hour in a 65 mile an hour
Lane and make it you know inflict me
with a longer and more expensive ride
because I'm so annoying as a customer
but I've got a habit of
small Stakes practice for high stakes
results and who do I get to practice on
the Lyft drivers on a regular basis the
guy behind the counter at the hotel uh
the TSA guy I'm going through TSA the
grocery store clerk the Starbucks person
the only way I'm at my best in my
negotiations is just trying to keep my
negotiation muscles limber
by interacting with people throughout
the course of my day and then ideally
you know leaving them better than I
found them you know try and try not to
leave negative karma in my wake trying
to leave as much positive karma in my
wake as possible
I love that and I'm very familiar with
the feeling of needing to conserve my
voice for podcasting or energy for
things and yet I'm somebody who's I
think genuinely curious about what
people's experiences are so I like the
question
um you know how's your day going it's
pretty open-ended
um it's I suppose if somebody was really
upset that would be perhaps the worst
question I could possibly ask
um from what you just described but I
don't put a fine point on it too because
like I've manipulated him with what do
you love about
because there's it you watch them change
in the moment to immediately to shift
into this concept of love which is more
than like what do you like about driving
forklift what do you love about driving
for left I I can trigger a state change
in you
instantaneously no matter what kind of
mood you're in because this guy was in a
very bad mood
plus Additionally the download from that
typically is so quick
I'm going to get a real clear picture on
who you are really really fast
I'm talking to a CEO of a company a
couple of months ago
they're they're the you know for lack of
a better term they're delivering clean
water to the world
and I'm like that's a cool Mission like
I dig this as an entrepreneur
an entrepreneur want to make a dent in
the universe
I dig that like I'm trying to make a
difference in the world
so I say to him what do you love about
what you do for a living immediately
fires back at me I love leading teams I
Love Leading teams
and I love giving shareholders a great
return on their investment it's really
important for me to give shareholders a
great return and then yeah you know we
deliver water and then he said a fourth
thing and I thought this guy could be
doing toilet paper
he doesn't care about the mission of the
company at all
he's a great CEO probably because you
want a CEO to lead teams
you want a CEO to deliver a corporate
CEO to deliver a return on investment
for shareholders
but that's why he's a great corporate
CEO
and not a great entrepreneurial CEO
so by him giving me that download real
quick that was blatantly honest
like do I think this is a great guy yeah
do our core values line up my mission is
more important to me than his mission is
or his mission is making money
now I like making money but it's not
number one it's a strong number two
but that question instead of how are you
today
to what do you love about
you immediately put them in a better
place plus you get some ridiculously
candid answers that tells you who they
are real fast
what is the best way to approach
our response to somebody who's asking to
be heard
perhaps they've got complaints maybe
about us maybe about somebody else you
know people are venting right people
seem to vary on the
propensity to vent Spectrum some people
just you know they vent all the time
this happened that happened and you know
and they want to complain you know the
uh the way it sometimes describes they
love to take other people's inventories
they love to take inventories of
everybody else's mistakes they did this
they did that
um you know it's it's a lot easier some
often than taking our own inventories of
what we could be focused on and do
better that's that's a universal truth
in my mind but you know people approach
other people that they trust and they
want to vent
presumably to get over whatever it is
that is bothering them but all too often
it seems to just amplify the feelings of
frustration
what do you do when somebody you care
about and that cares about you comes to
you to vent is it just you let them you
let them vent or do you
um do you try and let them negotiate
with themselves a little bit in a way
that could help them more than if you
were to just let them vent
I'm really leery of letting people vent
because a lot of times it just they
never it seems to be a spiral that just
spirals out of control
um so how do why is somebody vented they
don't feel hurt they feel ignored they
feel like they've been wasting their
time talking they're frustrated
that's the feedback I'm gonna give you
feedback on what I'm guessing cause is
causing you to vent
in just an observation like it sounds
like this is this is driving you crazy
because nobody listens to you
sounds like you've been struggling with
us for a long time
sounds like this is very frustrating for
you
um what's the emotion
the particular negative emotion
frustration is about somebody being
denied a goal in the future
anger is about somebody who's upset
about something happening in the past
the type of negative emotion begins to
focus you in on
where they is it Forward Thinking or is
it backward thinking
and frustration and anger can be two
very different versions of the same
negative emotion but they're focused on
different points in time
so I'm going to try to intuitively if I
don't if I don't know um from what
you've told me I'm going to start taking
educated guesses
on making an observation on what it is
that's driving you if you need to vent
you've been talking and people been
ignoring you
or you've been taking actions and people
have been ignoring you it's a it's you
need to vent because your communication
reactions have been ignored there are
some Clues here and the sooner that I
get at the heart of what's bothering you
the sooner you're going to be able to
let it off so I'm going to encourage
letting the steam off
without trying to correct you without
giving you advice
um without frustrating you by not
listening to you by trying to recognize
verbally what some of the motivators are
which will deactivate the anger much
more quickly it's the whole basis for a
crisis hotline to begin with
people are venting
and so how do you most effectively vent
somebody so that instead of going on a
rant for an hour
and the rant
introduce toxins into their system where
they're poisoning themselves I think
negative emotions put toxins in our
system
you know how do I deactivate that as
quickly so that you're not hurting
yourself as much and and you you feel
heard you feel relieved you feel
listened to
so I'm gonna and if it involves me if
it's a close friend who's venting to you
you're involved in a situation to some
degree
and I might even say boy it feels like
you're probably frustrated because I
haven't listened to you up to now you
know I'm going to talk start taking some
emotionally educated guesses on what I
think is driving you and I'm gonna put
in the form of a label which is just an
observation seems like sounds like looks
like
then if I get it wrong and you go that's
not it at all I can say well that's just
the way it seems
it just seems that way
it puts you in a position to to just let
somebody know you see them and you're
doing your best to understand
I'm I'm not a fan of venting I if if I
go on a rant
personally I always feel worse
so I want to deactivate that negativity
so I can get get my feedback under me
emotionally
very useful knowledge you just shared
with us
do you meditate
tiny little bits I mean and trying to
make my day more effective I have a
gratitude exercise
that I do almost every morning
um other ways to make myself effective I
actually I'm looking at the non-sleep
deep rest
practice over the
because I you know I like to make use of
my time so and you know I'm spiritual so
um I'm I'm talking to the almighty on a
regular basis you pray I do yeah the
morning and night when you need to both
yeah both I mean I think
you know whether or not you believe in
one God or the universe or whatever it
is I think spiritual spirituality is an
important component of Health whatever
your spirituality is you should
recognize it and you should
you'll be better off
if you engage in some sort of a
spiritual practice doesn't have to be
any of the three major religions you
know but spirituality is a component of
who we are so yeah I practice it on a
regular basis so a sense of higher power
or
um to better Define higher power it
could be as you said with aligned with
conventional religion or just aligned
with the idea that there are things
outside of us that are important to pay
attention to that we can all do better
by being in recognition of or service to
or or both yeah something like yeah
pretty much pretty much like that and
and then leaving it as open and as as
possible
because there I think there's a
spiritual nature to us period
I agree
what about your physical training I I
must say you know you're um you're in
excellent shape I imagine that went
along with the FBI thing I mean I saw
Silence of the Lambs at the beginning
she's running around uh with other
agents yeah
um shooting targets and running and
lifting and doing their sit-ups and
they're you know that was a I think it
was a 1980s film so it was a little bit
dated now probably now they're they're
doing other stuff as well
um but you know nothing nothing works
like the basics so
um was the FBI the first time you got
serious about Fitness or prior to that
were you in were you an athlete and into
fitness and what are you doing nowadays
to maintain your frankly impressive
shape
um well thank you for the compliments
um
Sports Athletics Fitness was always a
part of my life
I was into sports but not particularly
good at them
uh football basketball
um then you know I'm a last century guy
so long before
the conditioning is involved as evolved
as it is now with interval training and
the rest of this stuff which is
phenomenal
you know weightlifting was introduced to
my high school my senior year you know I
lifted weight some continued through
college
a little bit of time in a martial arts
ripped my knee apart in college in the
martial arts but yeah Fitness has always
been
a part of my life as much for liking to
be in condition and you know the
spiritual regeneration of it whether I
knew what it was or not
um these days you know I'm looking for
every hack there is I know you don't
like the term hack not well we like
mechanisms scientists like mechanisms
yes yeah hack sort of implies that we're
using one thing to accomplish something
different I like mechanisms but at the
end of the day if people want to call
something a hack because it gets them
the result they want or they're more
it's more appealing to it to apply the
tool that's what matters to me you know
tools sitting in a box don't do anything
so people are using them then I'm good
with the term yeah yeah so what these
days cold plunge sauna principally I'm
struggling with issues with a couple of
joints that I know science will
eventually help me regenerate so in the
meantime
good diet you know the basic pillars
diet uh not a uh not a perfect diet but
by and large
overall my diet's pretty good
um and then you know the uh the little
little things spiritual keeps me in
shape physically
the hitting a cold Plunge
uh is is challenging psychologically and
physically and the state shifter that's
for sure you don't need science to know
that uh 30 seconds or a minute in that
cold water is gonna change your
Chemistry for a long while afterwards
and for the better I believe yeah once
you get out people forget this they're
like I hate they call it the whole the
point is not how you feel while you're
in it you can feel proud of how you
navigate that portion but the point is
how you feel afterwards right well I
feel the old saying why do you hit
yourself in a in the hand with a hammer
because it feels so good when you stop
like that I like that
um smoking like somebody worked in New
York City for a long time
um out here we'd probably say something
different um you know it's like crystals
and lava lamps or something although
there are many lava lamps anymore I
think that the idea that California is
all hippie dippy that's not true anymore
I think it's been overrun by by other um
a different ethos in any event
um thanks for sharing that because I
think that we can't separate the
physical from the psychological right I
mean we've been talking about the mental
and fatigue status of the people you're
negotiating with oftentimes during this
conversation but then of course there's
how you show up to the job I mean if
you're run down three days and you've
been in a fight with your spouse and
that's still in the back your mind and
you're
um and you're hungry tired sick what you
know
um not connected to your higher power
all those things that there's no way you
can be as effective at any job so I it's
great to hear and not surprising to hear
that you have
um Bedrock practices that you you
implement
um especially yeah it's interesting
point almost everybody I knew that it
was really good at anything they did for
a living they probably took pretty good
care of themselves
yeah I agree you know there's this that
the language around self-care I think
gets really distorted I'm going to
editorialize for a second here I think
it um but I'm going to editorialize in
line with with what you just said
um you know I think self-care sounds
like Naval gazing where people think
that it's all about self but it's
actually
taking care of oneself so that we can
show up better for everybody else more
energy more capacity more staying power
to have those hard conversations with
the people we care about and that move
our life forward so it's really
refilling the the fuel tank in my mind
as opposed to
um the kind of uh egocentric
narcissistic
you know
stance that a lot of people take towards
that they and and I understand why they
do you know people scroll through
Instagram and they see
um people you know selfieing every every
muscle and like and all this stuff and
listen I'm not disparaging what people
want to do but but at the end of the day
self-care is about being
more ready to do better for the world if
you're or if you're Mission oriented
agreed completely agree
do you think there's been a change in
the FBI uh over the last 30 40 years
around that you know I have this image
in my mind of Agents like sitting in
cars for 20 hours eating hoagie
sandwiches and
um you know and uh looking through
binoculars and running themselves into
the ground with like this kind of
bulldog-like persistence to get to solve
the puzzle I mean put differently I
imagine there were some negotiations
that were very long and fatiguing so
um do you recall one of the longer
negotiations that you had and how do you
sleep at night Midway through a hostage
crisis
um
so the longest one that I was I was
directly involved in on almost day to
day and hour to hour one when it went
about three-ish days
Washington D.C
2003 start of the second Iraq war guy
named Dwight Watson rolled the tractor
into the middle of DC and claimed he had
four bombs and he left four bombs
scattered around
the city
had he actually done that or he was just
call he was bluffing he was bluffing he
hadn't done either
um
and started on St Patrick's Day
kind of interesting a couple you know
like that like the thing in um uh you
said in was in of the Philippines it's
like national holiday yeah holiday right
interesting uh for a whole bunch of
reasons now I and and I had to go home
and go to sleep
uh when one night and when we're in the
middle of that and then it was just
I don't remember having trouble going to
sleep because I felt like I did a good
job
um and that we handed I handed the shift
off to another hostage negotiator for
the bureau was effectively the team
leader of Vince stefanzo and Vince was
bringing a negotiator
so and the team that he was with I you
know everybody was in good hands
as a matter of fact Vince almost kicked
me out of the scene because I didn't
want to go and he just kept saying go
home get some sleep go home get some
sleep and finally the fifth time he said
it to me I went home
so I felt like I was leaving uh things
in really good hands
and we're working kidnappings we
expected them to go for long periods of
time and you just you just kind of gotta
it if you have faith in the process
and you feel like that you're doing the
best it can be done then I think you
could sleep at night
um
I guess to answer that question
you you have to be careful whether
you're working a a case of Siege or
um anything in in the bureau that you
don't run yourself into the ground
and there was some cases I worked in the
90s where I mean like we we knocked
ourselves out
like we would we worked harder anybody
we ever saw but we occasionally we took
time off too you know I worked with guys
that realized that sometimes you got to
go out and have a beard
kick back and blow off some some steam
so I think everybody that I ever worked
with were occasionally cautious enough
to recharge the batteries and then
depending upon the nature of the
challenge in front of you it was a Siege
in Saint Martin's Parish and went six
days I don't think those guys got a lot
of sleep but the nature of those sieges
in that particular type of sea generally
lasts five or six days anyway you just
gotta gut it out
were there ever instances where you're
just trying to keep the person on the
line so they can just raid
you know I I know I never had to do that
personally you had to be prepared to do
that
from the very beginning of any Siege
that you might have to get some you
might have to orchestrate an assault of
some sort I was fortunate enough early
on in my training there's kind of a
famous Siege in if you know hostage
negotiation history in London
called a princess gate Siege
where um a legendary British hostage
negotiated David Van Ness had the bad
guys on the phone while the SAS was
hidden hitting the building
and I remember that we were shown like
look there may come a time
when you have to keep somebody on the
phone when SWAT comes in that goes with
the territory
so expect that's a possibility from the
very beginning and it was a great Siege
um the bad guy Saleem the photos of him
after he was shot the phone is within
his reach David kept him on the phone
I've heard the tapes
the breaching explosions were going on
and
um slim says I gotta go I gotta go
there's suspicious noises and David Van
Ness in his classic British accent said
Salim
there are no suspicious noises
now let's get back to talking about how
many people are going on the bus to the
airport
bam and and they went in and and I
caught up with David a number of years
later I had a FBI pres I had a
presidential intern from the White House
internal with me in the bureau
we're drinking in a bar with David Van
Ness I got a lot of stories where I'm
drinking at a bar with somebody
and the intern walked around everybody
and tapped David on the shoulder and he
says uh Chris says you kept the
Terrorist on the phone up to the moment
that the SAS came in the door
and David says yeah and I already kept
him on the phone even longer if the SAS
had hadn't come in so soon
so
why am I telling that story if you're
going to get into that line of business
you got to accept all the things that go
with it and realize that it's not you
that made the decision somebody else did
you got to implement the strategy
you remember a case uh in Sacramento
where I think it was a youth gang
took over like an electronic store good
guy Siege yeah I remember this when I
was a kid there are two things that that
stand out in my mind from when I was a
kid one was the um Good Guys was the
name of the electronic store right good
guys with electronic store and uh bad
guys uh so to speak went in there took
them hostage and um I must have been a
kid this must have been like late it was
a late 80s 80s or something like that
um I remember that case um
89 or 90. I I knew one of the
negotiators that was 15. so I was born
in 75 so
um and as I recall they ended up opening
fire on a bunch of hostages who were
laying down on the ground is that right
they um they they knew that they were
getting ready to execute the hostages
because they put bags over their heads
and that whenever the bad guys do
anything to dehumanize a hostage
it's easier to shoot somebody with a bag
over their head than it is not
because you can't see their face
and so the bad guys had begun that
process and they knew they needed to
assault
God forbid anyone should ever be taken
hostage
I realize circumstances differ but you
just mentioned
putting bags over their heads there's
this notion of sheeple that you know
people will describe
um
post-hoc after something about how you
know somebody walks into a building
tells people to you know put zip ties on
their own ankles or go into a back room
that nobody resists and that in
retrospect had somebody caused a
commotion
they might have caused enough of a
commotion to either run out or be let go
um and yet of course there's a very
logical part of everybody's brain I
would hope that thinks listen this
person is an aggressor there's a gun in
my face don't be an idiot right because
we also have heard of the case in New
York City that I read about this in the
newspaper so presumably it's true where
someone was held up at gunpoint and one
of the women in the group that was held
up said what are you gonna do shoot us
and the person shot them right so that
happens too so you know
um I don't know if there's a a fair and
safe answer to give people on this but
if you're told to do something by
somebody and it's all happening in real
time I mean you have to ask do they want
my money in my body my life or some
combination of the three right in real
time while under presumably significant
duress
um but for hostages like if they if they
disobey cause a commotion is that
extending their life or is it shortening
their life I guess it it's very context
dependent right
um the only thing that I could without
knowing the context anything you could
do to humanize yourself and comply with
what the bad guys want increases your
chance of survival
so let's say you got ordered to go in a
back room you could look at the hostage
taker and say I'll do whatever you say
I'm Chris
you know drop your name on them in a way
so that you go from being a faceless
person to somebody with a name that
increases the chances of your survival
humanization whatever you can do to
comply simultaneously become more of a
human being because it's the opposite of
what I was talking about before
if you're easier to kill if you've been
dehumanized you're harder to kill if
you've been humanized you're harder to
harm like maybe they're not going to
kill you they're just gonna they're just
gonna hurt you they're less likely to
harm you if they know your first name
how do you get them as a hostage
negotiator if they if they talk about a
hostage I'll say you you know you mean
you mean Sheila
do you mean Rex
you know I'll find a way to drop the
person's name into the conversation so
as soon as if if you can humanize just
by
getting them to know your name you
increase the chances of survivability
you increase the chances of being
treated better and and comply I'll do
whatever well I'll do whatever you say
I'm Chris
is gonna is gonna start to move the odds
in your favor
you know that what you just described
extends to uh science
um you know I've talked before about my
stance on animal research and um why I
choose to no longer do it
um I do think it has its place in making
important discoveries that cannot be
made on humans but that eventually
extend to oh you don't want to do it I
don't want to do it personally I don't
want to do it and I don't want to do
primate work or large carnivore work or
small carnivore work but um the point I
was going to make is that when you do
primate work
um
they strongly discourage
near forbid you from giving them names
right they give them numbers right right
right right right so it all falls in
line with what you were what you were
talking about because the moment
something has a name it moves from being
a research animal to a pet of sorts and
that makes it a relationship right so
interesting how a name turns something
from a you know it elevates something to
a relationship however insignificant it
it's up a notch
an entire empathy circuitry yeah yeah
yeah which is uh perhaps the appropriate
segue to talk about empathy this is a
topic that uh you spend a lot of times
you uh you mentioned tactical empathy
right documentary by the way when is
that going to be out or do we have some
sense my guess is uh we'll finish
jumping through all the hoops and
probably have out at the beginning of
next year
we're um I'm currently working with
William Morris Endeavor on a couple of
different projects they've been
enormously supportive and we've asked
for their guidance on uh how to how to
the best time to get the documentary out
and very happy with the people I'm
dealing with there
and actually stroke of the universe was
looking out for me funny set of
circumstances and just really enjoy with
the people that I'm working with there
so probably first part of next year
fantastic
what's your take on empathy I think of
empathy in the pop culture sense of you
know somebody's feeling pain and we feel
their pain but of course empathy extends
way beyond that
yeah yeah yeah and that was um uh Rob
malenka yeah my colleague at Stanford
yeah I was I was really fascinated by
the conversation that you you had with
him on that recently and so and he said
a lot of people use empathy a lot of
different ways sort of for their own
meanings so
um
my take on empathy tactical empathy
also to keep drawing names out because
people give me thoughts and I want to
Source them out I'm very close to
Stephen Cutler's perspective on it and
Stephen would say empathy is about the
transmission of information compassion
is the reaction to the transmission I
like that and by the way I'm a fan of
Steven's work I think he I think he's
quite astute and a boy is he a hard
worker he writes like a beast I think
he's up at like four in the morning he
also has like 50 Chihuahuas or something
crazy he's weighing the dogs yeah yeah
well you can fit more Chihuahuas in a
room than any others gotcha Steven
but yeah so um and and that was when I
was with the FBI we started
collaborating with Harvard because the
Harvard definition
um was empathy was not liking the other
side
it was just demonstrating an
understanding of their perspective
um Bob manukin's book beyond winnings
chapter the tension between empathy and
assertiveness he says empathy is not
agreeing disagreeing or even liking the
other side
which sort of falls into what Stephen
talked about you know it's about the
transmission of information now empathy
is very compassionate thing to do
but it doesn't necessarily equate to
compassion itself if I'm if I do if I
let you know if I make you feel heard by
me saying to you what your perspective
on something is
you're going to feel cared for you're
going to feel understood it's going to
land with you really well
I don't necessarily have to feel
compassion for you I know it's a
precursor to compassion so I would
separate it from sympathy clearly
and I would even separate it from
compassion although I know it's a very
compassionate thing to do it's about
tactical empathy is about me actively
demonstrating verbally
to you that I understand where you're
coming from
tactic from The Experience on hostage
negotiators
backed up by Neuroscience
is that people largely react negatively
so the smarter move for me instead of
trying to reinforce a positive is to
First deactivate the negative by simply
calling it out calling the elephant a
room out
don't deny the elephant don't ignore the
elephant call The Elephant a room out
say
it probably going to sound like I'm
greedy
if I expect that you're going to think
I'm overreaching I'm not going to say I
don't want you to think I'm greedy I'm
going to say it's probably going to seem
greedy
so simply
well-educated emotional intelligence
influence gut instinct influence on what
the other side is thinking and feeling
if I can Define it in that way then it
becomes an unlimited skill if it
requires me for to have compassion for
you when I don't
then that limits my ability to use
empathy and I'm not interested in having
that ability to be limited I want it to
be an unlimited skill
so if you just if you just Define it
strictly in terms of transmission of
information
then it's not sympathy or Compassion or
liking or green it has a very powerful
effect it at least feels like compassion
to the other side
it reacts with the emotional circuitry
the neurochemicals that everybody has to
some degree if they're alive even if
they're on this the spectrum they have
some of that going on inside
and of what I've read on even even a
mental illnesses
uh in my last century training I saw
people who were paranoid schizophrenic
is it effectively be more of a wiring
problem than a chemical problem
for for Layman's description
and a lot of what I've read said
empathy's even effective with paranoid
schizophrenics people regardless of how
uh
disarray the circuitry in their head is
it's uh it helps them
on some level to feel understood
so empathy is just about letting
somebody feel understood
example when I'm working terrorism we
had a lot of
Arab Muslims testify an open civilian
court against a legitimate
Muslim cleric who was also a criminal
who also committed crimes
and
I would sit down with them and I'd say
to him right off the bat because I know
where they're coming from you believe
that there's been a succession of
American governments for the last 200
years that have been anti-islamic
and they'd look at me and they go like
yeah
I never said I it was true I never said
I agreed I never said I disagreed
by me simply articulating what their
perspective on the interaction was they
were so startled by it
was empathy
and and
we were so good at that empathy
frequently in that in that time frame
they would say are you are you Muslim
and I'd say no I respect the religion
you know if you need to know you know
I'm a Christian
but I respect your religion and I I got
no problem saying to you where you're
coming from that's empathy
from my definition and then it becomes
an unlimited skill I don't have to feel
it
I don't have to necessarily want to do
anything about it you know Goldman says
there's cognitive empathy me just
recognizing where your emotions are
coming from there's emotional empathy me
feeling your emotions and there's
empathic concern me wanting to do
something about your distress
my version of tactical empathy
probably brings those into play in
sequence on a Continuum of sorts
but none of them are precursors it's
just me showing to you that I understand
where you're coming from and it has a
phenomenally favorable impact on the
interaction
tell me about mirroring as a tool yeah
mirroring is a one of the simplest
easiest and most effective of the skill
set takes the least amount of brain
power it's just repeating one to
three-ish words of what somebody's just
said uh can be one it should never
usually be more than five
hostage negotiators learn it by
repeating the last one to three words
that somebody's just said it doesn't
have to be the last one to three words
and the mirroring is not the body
language mirror it's not mimicking
anybody physically and it's not
mimicking their tone of voice or
their affect or anything about them it's
just repeating one to three-ish words
we found that accesses for whatever part
of brain you uh that you got to energize
to do it it's it's a different part of
the brain than labeling people are
usually either good really good at
labeling like I label
almost everybody on my team labels a lot
sounds like this is bothering you
sounds like seems like you're just not
really sure where this is going
and the the mirror I gotta consciously
make it a point to mirror
and what's a mirror used for it's in
place of what did you mean by that
or would you please go on or I don't
understand could you repeat that again
so I'll listen for stuff that either I
don't understand
or I need you to talk more about
and instead of saying could you say some
more about that
I'll just mirror the words now for
whatever reason
it connects the thoughts in your head
the message the way that lands is
I heard what you said the words
I got the words because I just repeated
them and I still don't understand
so I need a more in-depth explanation
without using the same words that you
just used because if you say
um I think I suppress
actualism is is useless
and I might say what do you mean by that
and you go isopractorism is useless you
repeat the same words only louder you
figure that saying a ladder will make it
penetrate my cranium
that doesn't work
I need you to read to explain to go into
more depth to expand using different
words and for whatever reason
we found as hostage negotiators that I
find in business
that if I mirror you
you'll expand and you'll connect so it's
I use it in that context
I might use it to get you to hear
yourself out loud
like if what you just said doesn't make
sense
I'll repeat it backward for word one to
three words and I'll upward inflect I'll
say that that doesn't make sense
you know use use my tone make it land
with my tone so you can hear yourself
out loud
somebody else just pointed out to me the
other day that
if you're talking to somebody and
they're in mid thought and they kind of
their voice Trails off because they sort
of lost their train of thought
if you mirror them there
that helps them get their train of
thought back
and expand
so it's it's a ridiculously effective
communication tool to get people to
expand and feel heard
its Simplicity puts some people off
there are some people that say yeah it
sounds stupid I don't see what good that
will do
I always notice if somebody's really
wants to know about mirroring
my description is they're both high IQ
and high EQ and why does that work a
high IQ guy is going to want to know
something that's really simple that
doesn't take any effort to do
and that's what a mirror does it's
really really effective it's almost no
effort on your part at all
interesting I must say that Neuroscience
has a um an unfortunate dearth of
knowledge about how brains interact this
is starting to change but most of what
we know about how brains work is from
putting people into functional magnetic
resonance imaging machine so-called MRI
exposing them to movies or games that
they have to play Etc and then looking
at brain state activation there are a
few Laboratories starting to look at how
people interact in real time with both
people in separate MRI machines that
hopefully will be able to parse some of
this and I'm certain that somebody
hearing this will use this knowledge to
go do the experiment if not I'll I'll
run out the flagpole to some uh highly
qualified people at Stanford who could
who could do this because it'd be fun to
see what's happening but I have the
sense that what's happening is that
there is a real merge of cognition when
one hears their own words right spoken
back to them that
um well it's you know you've now got two
brains processing the same information
and that has to lead new places so
um I don't have any um insight as to
where what exactly is happening but um
certainly that something is happening
there right right evidenced by the real
world results that you're getting we
don't need experiments to tell us that
um but it'd be interesting to to see and
learn a bit of what's happening if
there's a fusion for instance of a
co-activation of emotional centers
co-activation of there's something about
hearing our own voice
is very different than hearing other
people's voices most people cringe when
they hear their own voice on recording
right
um most not all
um some people are in love with their
own voice
um we know these people
but we know that our auditory system
cancels out
the hearing of our own voice did you
know that as we're talking now our
auditory system is suppressing our own
voice we don't really hear ourselves
speak the same way that when you speak I
hear you speak yeah so um it's an active
neurochemical inhibition of the response
and it's amazing too because as we grow
up our voice changes puberty and so
forth and other ways too that the vocal
cords change in thickness Etc and our
voice changes but we always know self
from other in terms of voice and we
cancel out our actual auditory
perception of our own that's fascinating
and breathing and heartbeat we shut down
our response to self actively within the
brain that's fascinating so maybe
hearing back some of what we just said
allows us to actually hear what we just
said yeah well true and that's why
people sometimes all somebody needs is a
sounding board
so they can they can somebody else can
hear hear they can hear themselves out
and get repeated back to them and then
they go like wait a minute did I just
say that
yeah interesting
interesting
useful
indeed
proactive listening tell us about
proactive listening we're all told that
we need to be better listeners you know
the other day someone said we got two
ears in one mouth as if that's supposed
to remind us
um most people have two ears in one
mouth
um but I get the point they were saying
hey
there's value in listening and more
often than not we default to broadcast
but no reception we're mostly broadcast
less reception right
um hence the uh the call for nasal
breathing it's useful in a lot of
circumstances uh because it keeps us it
keeps our mouth shut
um what is proactive listening how do we
do it what's it good for I'm really
trying to get people out of the notion
of active listening just because active
listening has been so overused the
people have lost track of it and most of
it is taught poorly
and it's interactive versus proactive
and so we learned as hostage negotiators
first of all just to label the
presenting emotion and we just assume
that and the presenting emotion was
always anger of some form anger upset
on certain rare instances the guy was
under control but they were almost
always negative emotions so we just
assumed that it was uh defined to what
was uh confined to what was driving
hostage takers was negativity
now if I may
because now I feel like an imposter
talking about Neuroscience to you your
knowledge of Neuroscience is is spot on
uh Voss I I'm gonna say numerous times
you've asked me about things in
neuroscience and you've never been off
the mark so yeah you've clearly done
your homework too oh so we keep trying
to learn about it but um
Layman's terminology the survival brain
is largely negative
ballpark I would say 75 negative your
reactions are going to be negative so
number one I believe that's
principally backed up by the experiments
of Neuroscience the fmri have used
alluded to
and so then in hostage negotiation we
were taught to basically label the
presenting emotion
and then I've seen
experimentation or reporting of
experiments
um I think that first time I read about
it was in a book called The upward
spiral
and that book is a good 10 years old I
think which means you know the
Neuroscience is evolving but primarily
the experiment there that I remember
reading about and read about in other
places that if people were undergoing a
negative emotion
in my Layman's paraphrase of the
experiment is they've shown a picture
that induced the negative emotion in
their head and then they asked people to
Simply call out what the emotion was and
when they self-labeled
then the emotion diminished
now the degree of diminishment
varies
but the percentage of time that it
diminishes by simply by calling it out
is just darn near all the time
so for largely 75 percent negative and
we can deactivate the negativity
by calling it out well let's be
proactive if you're a human being and
we're engaged in a negotiation
there's going to be certain very
predictable negativity that's going to
be there
and I should be proactive in calling it
out
anticipating the negativity is going to
be there
based on a circumstances highly
predictable
and your gut instinct before you're
referring to when you want to say look I
don't want you to think I'm being greedy
your gut's telling you it's highly
predictable you're going to come off as
greedy
so let me be proactive and say it's
probably going to seem like I'm being
greedy
and that's the dialing over to what is
eminently predictable in the interaction
and just being proactive to deactivate
the negative emotions
that either are taking place or what our
experiences found then I haven't seen
any
science that is yet that has had the
opportunity
to back this up it inoculates
I can create a barrier if I call out a
negative that's not there it doesn't
plant it
it actually inoculates you from it if
and I've done this in practice I've I
was given a lecture a couple of years
ago
anybody asked a question I try to find
the value in the question no matter how
bad the question is
this poor guy asked me a question that I
just cannot find a single component in
his question
that demonstrates that he was listening
or paying attention there was nothing
about it that I could congratulate him
on
and so I said
this is going to sound harsh
because I know the answer I'm getting
ready to give him is going to make it
sound like to the group that I think
he's stupid
I just I can't think of a way to respond
to this without saying effectively like
what are you thinking about that's got
nothing to do what we're talking about
so I go this is going to sound harsh
and I answer the question and he just
kind of goes okay and I start answering
somebody else question and he goes
that wasn't harsh
now if I hadn't said this is going to
sound harsh
and answered the question
I guarantee you my answer would have
embarrassed them
and embarrassment is one of the worst
negative emotions you can inflict on
anybody and he would hate me to this day
for embarrassing him
so I got a moment coming at me that is
predictably negative
and I can let it I can let that train
run me down
or I can call that out in advance and
get a reaction where the guy says
it wasn't that bad
and that's what being proactive about
the emotions is about
I love it and I'm recalling an instance
during graduate school where my graduate
advisor who sadly has passed away but
was a phenomenal scientist I mean just
so pure
insisted on getting the answers could
emotionally detach from the answers and
she's just was it was a ninja she used
to come into the laboratory when we were
working on a paper and she'd sit down
and she'd say
You're Gonna Hate Me for what I'm about
to ask you to do and I think oh no like
I'm gonna have to redo all the analysis
or I'm gonna like some you know
Monumental thing and then she'd say
you gotta change the like fonts in
figure two
like oh my Godly what do you mean I want
to hate you but but it was relief but I
wanted nothing more than to make her
happy with my work because I I respected
the standard that she held so so greatly
um I mean she could have asked me to you
know stand on my head and do the
experiments 50 times I would probably
would have done it if I thought they
would make the project better and as a
consequence she would have been pleased
um because she was the standard for me
in many ways still is but I'm wondering
if she read your book because uh she's
depressed these
um requests with like you're gonna hate
me and then she'd ask me for something
like oh I hate you like that's nothing
but now I wonder if if I would have been
taken aback if she had just said uh you
know um hey by the way figure two needs
redoing I might have been kind of
bristled by that so um maybe she read
your book Chris
these are great tools mirroring and
proactive listening and thank you for
sharing these of course
did you ever employ the family members
of kidnappers friends of kidnappers as a
means to kind of um tap into a different
aspect of their psyche you know because
I think that we are all as human beings
very context
driven so I can imagine that the person
who kidnapped somebody or who's
um trying to steal somebody's resources
is in a particular groove of the of
person and and I I do think there are
people in the world who are just evil
but I also know because I've read about
it and I trust the sources that there
are people who have done horrendous
things who love their dog
um and genuinely love their dog and
wouldn't harm an animal but I'm not
trying to give these people a pass but I
could imagine that
um those other facets to somebody
represent really good entry points for
allowing them to see the kind of
incongruence in their behavior
um or is it the case that when these are
high stress situations that you just
have to basically you know you have to
attack the you know disarm the aggressor
and you're just focusing on the person
as the bad actor not considering the
other contexts of their lives
all right so let's draw a distinction
between uh hostage takers in a contained
situation
and um kidnappers uncontained unknown
location
so you're probably asking about somebody
in a contained situation
uh bad guys in a bank Dwight Watson
in in his tractor in Washington DC
so very counterintuitively if they're in
a contained situation there's a saying
out there that says A system that you're
employing is perfectly designed to give
you the outcome that you have
so bad guy Dwight Watson
is
on his tractor in DC
the family's part of the system to put
them there
the blunt harsh reality of that is
now at that siege that went on long
enough and it was so high profile some
of his family members showed up
now we can we could and and did try to
use them I'm walking I'm walking from
one place to another
from the negotiation operation uh cell
component on the way to command post
hostage negotiator stops me a couple of
people with them it's Watson's family
and they see I'm in a hurry
and that I'm not interested in being
stopped and they got to say to me
something to stop me and get my
um attention and they go look our
brother's just hurting in his heart
he's just hurting
you know things have gone bad for our
whole family and he's just hurt in his
heart
don't kill him over that
and I looked at the negotiator and I
said get that on tape
and we'll play that for him
because if we can get that on tape
exactly the way they said it that'll
land
but if we put them on the phone with
them they're going to try to reason with
them
and they're going to say stuff to them
they didn't help
which they don't very well intention but
it's going to be counterintuitive
and it's probably going to make it worse
so you have to understand family can be
extremely important if you can get them
to say exactly the right thing
and it's probably going to need to be
highly
orchestrated because you know how it's
going to land and unfortunately if you
get them in a direct conversation it'll
probably renew an old wound you know
family members have hurt each other in
ways that they have no idea even
happened
and so the other you know a family
member my son to this day remembers when
I told him Santa Claus wasn't real and I
have no what
I have no memory of that conversation
I'm sorry I blew it for you right man
wait we got oh my goodness the family
members have heard each other over the
years that they have no idea which comes
up in these live conversations
and you don't know what what wounds you
don't even know what wounds are there
that you caused and so in in a contained
situation a family member can be
extremely helpful
but it has to be it's it's a surgical
shot that you have to be really really
really careful with otherwise it can go
the other way because the wounds and
people don't even know are there such a
psychologically astute way of viewing it
because I'm a big fan of the so-called
family systems model of psychology I
mean you can't look at any human being
psychology
positive meaning adaptive or maladaptive
psychology and not look at the family
system which that evolved which is not
to say that some perfectly healthy
families occasionally don't have issues
with a child having mental illness and
and I mean that happens but I'm told
that
99.9 of the time
you can identify a family system
organization or a lineage a genetic tie
Etc that that makes things start to make
sense when somebody's really struggling
right right and and as you pointed out
sadly oftentimes that that involves um
Pains of past
um
wow well thanks for sharing that because
I I think that um in my mind the movie
version of it is you know they bring the
mother in and it's like Billy don't do
it you know and then as you said Billy
might like that might be the time when
Billy's really gonna let his mother know
you know her childhood sucked for Billy
right and that's not what you want yeah
goodness what a complex job what a
complex high stakes High consequence job
what did you do to unload some of the
heaviness I don't I'm not just talking
about getting a good night's sleep or
having a a beer with your co-workers
afterward although those things sort of
you know important roles for um for
people I realize
um you know
do you think we can dump
the hard stuff in our head in our hearts
in a way that um
you know allows us to be functional
because you know people in your line of
work and I think just anyone in the
world you live long enough you're gonna
you're gonna experience loss yeah you're
gonna get kicked in the in the gut yeah
and you're gonna see people you care
about get kicked in the gut there that's
there's so much Beauty to life as well
but but that's the reality so
um did you do you have
tools processes that you use to kind of
dump the baggage so you can lean into
your relationships and your relationship
to yourself with
with restored sense of optimism
um yeah I think mostly most of the
people that I've always worked around
we've
been very reinforcing of one another
um comedically
emotionally friendship wise
you know being able to laugh with each
other taking it easy on each other
getting people you know laughter
and genuine understanding with with uh
without
um
you know somebody trying to tell you
that you did wrong
I've been lucky enough to either find
myself in those groups most of the time
or we we just evolved it that's just the
way that we were we were attracted to
one another emotionally psychologically
because of that
that's probably it mostly I mean I've
tried to parse some of these emotions
out recently
like I'm not particularly proud of
anything I've ever done
but I always felt like it was a
privilege like you must be a proud of
your accomplishments I don't know that
it's Pride but there's uh there's other
satisfaction that I get out of it and so
thinking about what drives me also now
you know that I'm running a company and
I'm and I got people also entrepreneurs
that are trying to do the best for their
employees
you know what do we encourage in one
another
so that whatever we're doing people feel
good about it and I try to take a lot of
that from
what I learned as an FBI agent and a
hostage negotiator and the people that I
was around
and you know we did joke with each other
a lot and we did
um play tricks on each other
you know good good-natured humor avoid
the people that are running you down
but be able to uh you know take take
some good natured ribbing every now and
then and I think humor is is uh one way
or another combined with hard work and
an appreciation for what you're doing
um it's probably been most of uh the
mental health along the way
occasional bourbon
love it
um we did a whole episode on alcohol and
so people are going to hear me say love
it and think oh wait here I'm supporting
out listen the data say as long as
you're not an alcoholic
as long as you are of age probably two
drinks a week is or less is safe uh make
them make them good high quality drinks
if you're going to have them
consume them in the right context or
don't consume them at all but
um that's what I said love it I I
support your your love of bourbon
um I'm not bourbon drinker but
um
tell me a little bit more about what
you're up to lately you alluded to it a
moment ago that you're running teams
that are doing a lot so you're in charge
of a lot of people now helping people
help people
um providing a lot of service in the
world through a lot of different
channels
um first of all I want to say that your
book never split the difference one of
my favorite books thank you um I don't
say that lightly I don't endorse books
very often but the books I do endorse I
love love love I also have to say that
it's a toss-up between your book never
split the disc difference and the body
keeps the score for the award for best
titles of any book those are just like
amazing titles amazing amazing titles
Paul Ross or uh co-writer came up with
the title yeah it's a phenomenal title
that in the body keep this keeps the
score just like because there's so much
contained in in the title and then the
book um exceeds expectations so uh
really amazing book people should listen
to it read it if they haven't already
but you're doing a lot more right now
than
um than just writing although I want to
hear about your other book projects as
well but before you list off the number
of things you're doing tell me first
about Fireside because this sounds like
a really interesting
um Endeavor that frankly I haven't heard
of before what's Fireside a brand new
social media platform it's essentially
an interactive podcast it's a
subscription service founded by Fallon
fatimi and Mark Cuban follow and I have
been friends for a number of years she
was Google's youngest employee she's an
entrepreneur Dynamic smart hard charging
person
and it's
sort of grew out of what's inadequate in
some of the social media apps that are
out there
trying to combine the best ideas of a
few different things and found suggested
it to me and I thought I'll jump in
because she's a visionary
and what has turned out to be is it's
effectively weekly Interactive Group
coaching
and you you get the app off your iPhone
or your Android whatever platform your
phone is on
and then you log in we do an hour once a
week and it's you're getting group
coaching and then you get asked
questions
and it's got a video component to it so
if you want to ask a question we we're
going to bring you up on quote stage and
I get to see you and talk directly to
you and you get to see me and talk
directly to me or and I interviewed Mark
Cuban a couple of weeks ago and people
got to come on and ask Mark questions
or ask me questions
and what it has turned out to be is just
one of sort of uh uh the the next level
of how to get better at negotiations
after you've read the book and probably
taken to Master Class
you know where do you go next one of the
people that came on the podcast the
other day the the Fireside
episode they said well I don't have
enough money yet to go to your in-person
training events because those are
expensive
and this is how I'm going to get better
in the in a meantime and and work my way
in that direction
and so
the monthly coaching if you were to sign
up for group coaching from us on a
regular basis on a monthly basis
it would probably easily cost you for
what we're providing twenty five thirty
thousand dollars a month
and this is a thousand a year
so at scale
it's an opportunity to interact directly
with me and the members on my team once
a week and get group coaching and it's
and it's just kind of fun we're getting
a kick out of it and people that really
really care about interacting well with
people
guy comes on the first episode I did and
he said
besides the fact that you helped me make
a lot more money you helped me save my
marriage
and he just needed to know how to talk
more genuinely and honestly
with his wife in a way that made her
felt heard
and he didn't really have a good way to
do that beforehand
and I was just like
that's a lot I don't I don't I don't
know how to respond to that other than
just be grateful that
people can say stuff like that to us so
the Fireside thing is kind of cool we're
still experimenting with it
it's an interactive podcast group
coaching
it's fun
great I mean I would say uh you're
changing lives there I mean the saving a
marriage is no small deal and I think
that the ability to communicate
um directly with people also I imagine
gives them the opportunity to implement
the the tools that you're providing in
real time and that's one thing to hear
about something and and try it but then
uh you can give feedback in real time
are you on these these Fireside Chats
directly or members of your team no I I
do we do one every week and I'm once a
month and the other thing too like I can
explain something one way and if for
whatever reason it doesn't land in your
context you can't quite get it
so that's what we found about the
interactive nature of it somebody comes
on and asks a question in their context
and then I'll answer it and then they'll
go like oh oh oh oh okay all right that
helped so you get you get to hear people
like you who are struggling with it the
way you are but I haven't
put it in your context yet and that's
the other thing that's great about a q a
live q a
we had a guest on here who told me that
there are amazing data supporting the
fact that people follow the medical and
health advice of doctors that they can
relate to far more than they follow the
medical and health advice of the
Physicians that they feel aren't like
them
um
and oftentimes this can include the
physician or health care provider being
someone that they would aspire to be
like but oftentimes it's just some
common Rapport like they both like
baseball or they both like to cook or to
garden and that sets a bridge right
where then the patient is willing to do
all these things that ordinarily they
would be resistant to right and and
there are really good data to support
this and I I that that really stuck with
me because it says that it's it's not
just about the information or the the
delivery route or the information that
the context and the rapports even along
something is like oh you you're uh by
the way I'm not a major you know a major
sports fan on most things but you know
like oh you're a Bills fan or something
like me too like that can be the
difference between somebody doing all
the things to lower their blood pressure
or the day in changing their diet all
the all those things
versus not making the changes at all
Rapport is the magic yeah it's kind of a
magic component that changes
changes everything well Fireside sounds
like a great opportunity for people to
not just ask questions but to build
rapport with you and members of your
team so
um I'm gonna check it out Lord knows I
uh I need help improving my
communications and certain domains of
life
believe me I get the memos
um fact
um
what other writing projects are you
involved in
if any
um we're we've been toying it with this
uh companion uh operations manual
for tactical empathy
which
getting it right is important so it's
sort of a companion book to never spit
the difference that's probably at least
a year and a half out from being done so
in the meantime we just do we do a lot
of online training you know we got a we
got a newsletter we put out weekly
for for people to get our latest Cutting
Edge application thoughts as much as
possible we're putting information out
that we charge for a lot and we put out
a lot of free stuff
you know I'm I I'm throwing out ideas on
Instagram
but we're constantly trying to put
information out there so that so that
people can collaborate better
so specific we just finished a book for
residential real estate agents
a friend of mine Steve Shull we put that
out last November
that's sort of niched but it's mostly
the Black Swan method for real estate
agents because every conversation
they're in is a difficult emotional
conversation sell of a house is one of
the most stressful moments of anybody's
life selling or buying
so we just put that out in the meantime
you know we're
spreading gospel as much as possible
well we'll certainly point out the
various places people can find you and
and the different venues for for
learning more
I want to say that
um
numerous times throughout today's
conversation you threw out the words
sounds like as an opener and I have to
say I have this kind of crazy idea in
the back of my mind you know I believe
that
um simple field tested tools
are immensely powerful not just for
resolving negotiations but really for
changing the way that people interact
with each other and themselves and you
know if I have one wish uh for the world
uh on the basis of our conversation how
amazing would it be if kids learned
early on
to talk to one another from that sounds
like perspective because I think that
would naturally Orient them toward
listening
right or at least offering a hypothesis
of what they heard and how poorly they
might be listening and then getting a
defensive stance response that informs
them about the accuracy or lack of
accuracy
um and on and on I feel like the the
sounds like
um question sounds like you feel blank
or sounds like you believe blank just
seems to me like the
um like one of the
one of the most potent tools in the
universe and I sure wish that all adults
would implement it but that kids would
learn about it too
yeah that's that yeah that's that's a
great thought you know how how do we
teach them at a younger age that that
listening is actually an effective thing
to do it's actually a way to think
things through also
so I yeah I agree I mean
wave magic wand right
exactly well Chris I want to thank you
so much for your time today I I mean
you've joined us on this tour of so many
different facets of your work prior and
present and you've let us get a little
glimpse into the the portal of your
future work too which I'm eagerly
awaiting I also just want to thank you
for everything that you do you've always
struck me as such a giver of knowledge
and um you know you you can't put a
value on that you're constantly putting
knowledge into the world on Instagram
your book
um Fireside and courses and on and on
um glean from your experience in very
very intense circumstances but really
with an eye toward people getting the
most out of that for their their daily
lives which hopefully don't involve
hostage negotiations unless there are
hostage negotiator
um so I just want to say
um thank you ever so much for what you
do and for being such a phenomenal
communicator and also thank you for
doing into that late night FM DJ voice
yeah you know I've been I've wanted to
be uh here sitting with you being
interviewed on your podcast uh since I
first discovered it you thank you
several years ago and it's a privilege
to be here I really really and I love
what you're doing
in getting actionable usable tools into
the world so people can navigate more
effectively thank you right back at you
come back again all right thanks
thank you for joining me for today's
discussion with Chris Voss I hope you
found it to be as interesting and as
actionable as I did to find links to
Chris's website and to his excellent
book never split the difference as well
as to his social media handles please
see the links in the show note captions
if you're learning from and or enjoying
this podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on both
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a
five-star review if you have questions
for me or comments about the podcast or
topics or guests that you'd like me to
cover on the huberman Lab podcast please
put those in the comment section on
YouTube I do read all the comments in
addition please check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast not on
today's episode but on many previous
episodes of The huberman Lab podcast we
discuss supplements while supplements
aren't necessary for everybody many
people derive tremendous benefit from
them for things like improving sleep for
hormone support and for Focus the
huberman Lab podcast has partnered with
momentous supplements and we did that
for several reasons first of all their
ingredients are of the very highest
quality second of all they tend to focus
on single ingredient formulations which
make it easy to develop the most cost
effective and biologically effective
supplement regimen for you and third
momentous supplements ship
internationally which we realize is
important because many of you reside
outside of the United States to see the
supplements discussed on the huberman
Lab podcast go to live momentous spelled
ous so it's livemomentis.com huberman if
you're not already following me on
social media you can do so by going to
huberman lab on all social media
platforms so that's Instagram Twitter
now called X LinkedIn Facebook and
threads on all of those platforms I
cover science and science related tools
some of which overlaps with the content
of the huberman Lab podcast but much of
which is distinct from the content
covered on the huberman Lab podcast
again that's huberman lab on all social
media platforms if you haven't already
subscribed to our neural network
newsletter the neural network newsletter
is a zero cost monthly newsletter that
includes podcast summaries as well as
tool kits so tool kits for sleep
toolkits for Learning and plasticity
tool kits related to dopamine regulation
and much more again it's all zero cost
you simply go to hubermanlab.com go to
the menu tab scroll down to newsletter
and simply enter your email and we do
not share your email with anybody thank
you once again for joining for today's
discussion with Chris Voss and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in science
[Music]